so what what are you looking at when
you're in your mid-20s well I have to
build my career so I have any hope of
paying off this debt which means I don't
have time for like getting married and
having kids and then to think about
taking time away from your career to
have children well you're not going to
be keeping up with your wages you're not
going to be considered relevant or up to
date in whatever field you're working in
so a lot of women just don't ever get
there they just they're told that to be
a good smart girl and to be successful
these are the steps you have to do and
you'd better have a career in your own
money first that's like a prerequisite
to having children the last chapter of
the book is basically let's take a look
at this last hundred years of of
feminism since it became the dominant
thing and let's assess what we've gotten
out of it and where things stand all
women think that they're going to have
the high paying office job with the
corner window office and they're going
to be flying off to Paris or New York to
have power lunch is where they're gonna
you know close the deal and make all
this money they think they're going to
have this exciting career and she got
super angry and kind of like yelled at
me and was like because and she's
talking about her new husband who I
don't want to say his name but she was
like because I tell him what we're
eating for dinner I tell him what we're
spending the money on he doesn't have
his political opinions I tell him what
his political opinions are and who we're
voting for
today I'm actually so excited I have a
special guest Rachel Wilson
um she wrote the book occult feminism
the secret history of women's Liberation
this is her book right here I started
reading it and she's red pilling me even
further about feminism like I started
reading it and it's talking about how it
came from like like cult worship or
something yeah and I was like what so
I'm really excited to dive into these
topics Rachel welcome to the show well
thank you so much for having me I'm very
happy to be here everybody kept telling
me all you you and pearl have to get
together you guys would be great so I'm
very glad to be here yeah thank you for
coming and just before we start tell the
people where can they follow you find
you find your book yeah you can find my
book on Amazon you can follow me on
Twitter it's Rach the number four
patriarchy yes I want to restore
patriarchy and uh kind of rehabilitate
the term because it has such a negative
connotation that I don't think it
deserves so on Twitter at Rach for
patriarchy
um I also have a sub stack where I put a
lot of my writing if you are a reader
that's r wilson.substack.com
and I have a YouTube channel a little
baby brand new YouTube channel it's just
Rachel Wilson I would love to get you on
the show with some of these girls I
talked to let me tell you she's a
Superhero too you have five kids yes but
I feel like that's a that's beautiful I
grew up um I have nine siblings but it's
kind of a weird story I grew up with six
so in the house I had six and I will say
five is like the perfect number because
it's big and everyone fits in the car
barely what
you're too crazy six you start having to
like I don't know get the travel plus
yeah you've got to switch to a bus
that's what happened to the bus yep
okay so I want to tell you what I know
about feminism okay and I want you to
Red Pill me even further okay this is
what I want so from what I understand
feminism did it start with women getting
the right to vote or was it before that
it was before that so in the book I take
three chapters to kind of explain the
ancient origins of the ideas
philosophies and the like religious
underpinnings of feminist ideology and
then I kind of start with
um like the French Revolution the
revolutionary period is really when it
started to kick off most people do think
that feminism was like either during the
1920s with suffrage or in the 60s with
the sexual Revolution but it goes back
quite a lot further than that actually
so I do take some time in the book to
explain where it came from and how it
got going prior to the 1920s okay so
when when did it start 1800 1850 I'd say
like late 1700s is when you could really
call it a political movement really it
was that early yep okay and you said it
started Mary Wollstonecraft was probably
the first like popular feminist and she
was hanging out with American and French
revolutionaries in like the 1760s 1770s
60s okay so what did she do so she was
somebody who kind of forced her way she
kind of pushed her way into intellectual
male circles because she was having some
affairs with a lot of the prominent
Revolution writers of the time like
Thomas Paine and some of the French
revolutionaries and um
she she wrote like the first tract or
like a political tract about what she
thought were like the natural rights of
women and this all came from the
Enlightenment and the egalitarian idea
of like equality
um humanitarianism and so one of the
first things you would think of if
you're coming from that kind of a world
view is like gender equality so
um this was a time where we were
starting to see a shift towards more of
a material and biological worldview
where some of these women started making
the argument that hey just because I'm a
woman doesn't necessarily mean that I
can't do things men can do
intellectually and and we should be you
know this is the birth of nation states
and voting rights and things like that
so right off the gate you had some women
who wanted that but they were definitely
not popular with other women and they
weren't even popular with other men
except the other like really radical
left-wing revolutionary types okay so
they started by like infiltrating these
these male academic circles and talking
about so what did she say were the
natural like rights of women it's it was
pretty much the same stuff we're hearing
now where it's like I should have a
right to self-determination I should be
able to make my own money I should be
able to
um there was always an emphasis on
sexual freedom and reproductive Freedom
even back then really in the 70s wow
yeah and I think the reason is because
woolston craft so she tried to have a
three-way uh with a prominent writer of
her time whose wife was not having it
and kind of got her booted out of proper
English society for a while and she had
a child out of wedlock
um she was doing things during that time
that although you might think like when
you would do your um man on the street
interviews where you're asking people
their opinion most people's idea of
feminism is okay women have been
oppressed through all of history they
weren't allowed to do anything and they
were beaten and raped legally and life
was just terrible for women and they
were chained to a stove and forced to
give birth and cook meals and that's all
they could do and you know this very
Grim horrific idea of what life was like
for women until 100 years before now and
really that's not the case at all and I
take some time in the book also to
outline that woolston craft herself was
making a writing uh living writing
traveling
um doing political protests doing like
you know revolutionary activities she
was actually able to make herself a
living she had a child out of wedlock
nobody threw her in jail nobody stoned
her to death
um she was doing a lot of things that
you would probably think would you know
get her destroyed by the patriarchy but
she only got some mild pushback really
socially
um women weren't very interested in you
know being political and participating
in that part of life they were pretty
happy with where they were and this is a
common theme in these old feminist
writings that they are continually
disappointed that most women don't seem
interested in feminism
um so they had to kind of find ways to
mainstream it and make it more appealing
and so they would use a lot of the
things they do now like fashion and
literature and and uh you know
propaganda primarily so really so you're
telling me in the 1700s a girl was free
to work and make a living and she there
was no
yeah common was it do you know it wasn't
super common but not because it wasn't
allowed it wasn't common because most
women did at that time want to get
married and have families and have
security and this is just prior to the
Industrial Revolution really kicking off
so
um it wasn't super common but certainly
in in the west when we're going through
the revolutionary period there were a
lot of women who participated in
different you know revolutionary
activities and they tended to not get
their heads cut off as often as men get
thrown in prison as often as men so I
think they were also useful to the male
left-wing revolutionaries because they
could put a woman or two out there and
you know you're not going to get the
same brutality they they you know they
might get slightly admonished or
chastised socially but they weren't
going to get you know beheaded or thrown
in prison as quickly as men so I think
it was kind of a sneaky way like a male
feminist trickery kind of way to get
their political ideas to the Forefront
and not have to risk their own hives as
much so I think that was the other
reason some of them thought oh yeah
let's let's get some women in here doing
some of this stuff right and you
mentioned too that it was tied into
witchcraft yes and ancient religions
religions goddess like what is that yeah
so if you think about what feminism is
feminists love to say that feminism is
about equality and opportunity and
choice for women but it's not uh I think
you you have figured that out and a lot
of people are figuring that out and it
never was it's always been
um you had Christianity which is a
patriarchal religion and Christian
Society is patriarchal now that doesn't
mean abuse and oppression of women by
men patriarchy means the men kind of run
things they're in charge of governance
and things like that
um it and that women are provided for
and protected by men so in ancient times
goddess worship Cults like people who
followed inanna or Ishtar or people who
were into black magic and Witchcraft and
glorified like female demons such as
Lilith or the Hindu goddess Kali who
strangely is is on the cover of the very
first feminist magazine in the United
States Ms magazine in the 70s chose the
the bloodthirsty male sacrificing
goddess Kali to be on their cover which
is a super weird choice for a magazine
in the 70s that you're selling to
Suburban women but they chose her
because she represents sexual Freedom
Vengeance against men she wears a
necklace of bloody men's severed heads
and a belt around her waist of men's
severed arms and she actually had one of
the most prolific death Cults in all of
history in India it was called the
thuggies that's where we actually get
the English word Thug from
and they were a cult that worshiped Kali
the goddess and they would send they
couldn't sacrifice women because she'd
get really mad if she did that so they
would kidnap men and sacrifice them to
her and they're in the Guinness book of
records for being the most prolific
death Cult of all time they they went on
for hundreds of years doing this and
were responsible for millions of male
devices and that's who they put on the
cover of the first women's feminist
magazine in the 70s which was also
started with CIA money
so you have the CIA pushing this stuff
in the 70s as well okay I have so many
questions
I know it's a lot was this was this in
the 1700s too like there was this back
then like so were the women like the
Mary Walston craft was she part of that
got like did she do witchcraft and she
was more of like the the new brand of
atheists that they had after the
enlightenment where there was a lot of
pushback against traditional
Christianity a lot of pushback against
the church
um the revolutionary period was kind of
I mean what the name implies we're going
to revolt against the entire order of
things you know revolt against monarchy
revolt against the nuclear family
against patriarchy against the
established order that had been you know
the status quo in Europe for centuries
at that point
um so most of the more modern feminists
you will see some who are atheists but
you will see a lot in fact suffragettes
by and large were spiritualists many of
them were fortune tellers tarot card
readers they were um Spirit mediums
um and this was being a spirit medium
was a really popular thing in the 1800s
and most of the female speakers who
pushed suffrage claimed to be Spirit
mediums and part of that was because
they could get away with saying things
that they might not have been able to
get away with saying otherwise if you
say you're possessed by the ghost of
someone
and it's them talking not you you can
kind of get away with saying some things
that maybe you couldn't if you were
trying to say them as yourself so that
would be one reason
um
but yet there's always been this tie to
Witchcraft and goddess worship because
um that is the kind of the polar
opposite religiously and philosophically
of Christianity or even Islam where you
have this idea that women and women's
sexual power should be the dominant
force of society it should be the ruling
force of society and it was so it was
never really about equality it was about
subjugation of men if you look at um
goddesses like the Hindu goddess Kali
she's always pictured standing with her
foot on the chest of her male cohort
Shiva and she so it's always like this
idea that the goddesses are the ones
dominating the male gods and that using
their sexual power to manipulate and you
sort of see that today like okay I don't
know if you've noticed that you probably
have your red pill so I was like she's
based so okay when I watch movies and
I'll see like the women dominating the
men like in all the companies and stuff
and they just like walk around like girl
boss I'm like I don't see these women in
real life they're not real no they're
not
but it's kind of the same thing where
they're dominating all like they're
dominating their relationships they're
dominating at work and it it so it's
kind of the same like pattern I guess
yes my question is with Kali like so
this was a real tribe or something in
India yeah they're still around no
they're still around yeah it's part of
the Hindu religion um Kali is part of
the of Hindu religion but the cult
specifically got wiped out by the
British when they colonized India they
were like okay enough of this because
they were they would kidnap a lot of the
like British soldiers and things like
that and sacrifice them so they finally
it was the British that came and and
wiped out the death cult but goddess
worship is still around and it's very
popular in fact I believe Wicca is now
the fastest growing religion in the UK
yes uh Gerald Gardner who started Wicca
he was from England so it's very popular
there a lot of the things that we hear
about Witch Trials Witch Trials have
been very very whitewashed because
liberal Hollywood is always very
sympathetic to you know witches and um
you know which persecution and it's not
that there weren't some people who were
wrongly accused of Witchcraft or wrongly
executed because of it of course that's
true to an extent but there's a reason a
lot of people don't know why witches
were burned at the stake or otherwise
punished and that's because a lot of
times they also worked as midwives and
they were the ones that performed a
a question was only medicalized in the
1950s so prior to that almost all opens
through history have been performed by
midwives and many of The Midwives would
be practicing witches or into witchcraft
or other types of like mystical
practices so that's one of the reasons
that they were targeted not just because
the evil Christians just we're
superstitious and thought witches were
cursing them there was part of that but
a lot of it was these were the people
who were performing the abortions and
they wanted to eliminate that wait so
how how early were like how long was it
been around I don't actually even know
forever since ancient times we have like
a lot of ancient evidence of of emotion
happening and again it was usually in
like it was more prolific and goddess
worship Cults or like ancient Rome if
you had um polytheist
um religions things like that where you
had goddesses
um Liberation and uh Temple protection
and things like that went along with
those religions so sometimes it would be
an actual religious Sacrament if it was
like maybe a cult or a goddess worship
cult you would have Temple Prime and you
would have a as a result of that so
that's one of the main reasons for the
this persecution is like a lot of times
they were going after the providers okay
what I don't understand Kali they're
killing men how could they kill the men
because women are weaker than men
the cult was made of men they would
worship women and they would worship the
goddess Kali but who would actually
sacrifice other men to her because they
thought that Kali was the the life-giver
she was like the dark mother that gave
life to the world but she's also a
vengeful spirit that can destroy the
entire world she's like one of the most
powerful gods in the Hindu religion so
they always thought that if they were
going into battle or going to war or if
just generally if things weren't good
that Kali must be pissed off so we have
to find a bunch of round up a bunch of
young men and sacrifice them to her to
satiate her bloodlust because she hates
men wow okay so so in the all right so
in the 17 so basically the the room
fruits of feminism there's a lot of
parallels to some of these like goddess
where like these cult goddess worshiping
religion so one of them's Kali and one
of them and that that was the thuggies
where they would literally take men and
give them to the goddess the female
goddess it was the idea that sexual
like we should basically Bend to women's
like sexual Powers is that it okay okay
and so but in the 1700s it wasn't
necessarily that they're a part of that
religion right but there was more of
like the modern atheist but a lot of
atheists now still have remnants of the
Goddess stuff yes yeah because like I'm
just thinking like horoscopes I I think
is part of that oh yeah the what do they
say the the crystals
one of our dating shows I'm gonna keep
that away I don't know yeah all of all
of that stuff is it all comes from
ancient
ancient Crafton in the book in the book
I explain why like what like you're kind
of sitting there trying to piece it
together like but but why would modern
feminists be into this it seems like
superstitious and old-fashioned it's
because
um if you're raised in America or the UK
where you probably have a Protestant or
a Catholic upbringing even if your
parents don't go to church it's kind of
a culturally Christian area you grow up
as a young woman you're watching all the
propaganda you're seeing the Kick-Ass
chicks in the movies you're seeing um
cardi B and Megan the stallion you know
talking about using their sexuality to
get power and fame and money and you get
to college and you're even further you
know um
indoctrinated into feminism by your
professors and gender studies and all
these things you start to see
Christianity and even like cultural
Christianity as oppressive to women as
you know inherently holding women back
you start to resent that and but people
are still spiritual women especially are
still spiritual and they're intuitive
and so they need something and so when
they are introduced to something like
Wicca or all the different forms of uh
nice witchcraft that we have now like
you'll see people say oh I'm a green
witch which means I just worship nature
and I love plants and crystals and and
animals and things like that they're
very like Mother Earth worship which is
also an ancient religious idea
um it's very appealing it's very
appealing if you've been brainwashed and
propagandized with feminist messaging
because it tells you that you're
powerful that you're you should use your
sexuality to control and manipulate men
you should leverage your sexuality to
try to get money for yourself and status
for yourself and
um it it pits you against the enemy
which is men and it makes you feel like
you're the powerful one you know like
goddess worship is extremely that you
see it all the time on uh social media
where they'll be like yes Queen you're
such a goddess you know like this
language yeah this language is very
indicative of these really ancient ideas
of goddess worship and Witchcraft where
women are using their sexuality to
control and manipulate reality and
dominate men so so all right in the you
so how did these ideas come from like
India to the US well a few different
ways you had colonization so like the
British colonized India that's one major
way a lot of people would go there and
um live with you know people in Hindu
cultures or even Buddhist cultures and
bring back a lot of those ideas to the
west and write about them
um you would have the like like during
the Islamic invasions of Europe they
brought some some ideas that were
Eastern and then something I write a lot
about in the book is theosophy theosophy
was a religious movement from like the
mid to late 1800s onward it's now kind
of
um morphed into New Age mysticism that's
kind of where the new age comes from is
out of theosophy and that was an attempt
to blend Eastern Mystic religion with
like Western ideas like Rosicrucianism
so it's just basically an occult
religion and Aleister Crowley came out
of theosophy Helena blavatsky came out
of there and a lot of these people had
intelligence connections so we're
talking around the Victorian era a lot
of these people worked for British
intelligence or maybe British and
Russian intelligence or things like that
and they were traveling and speaking and
setting up worship centers and trying to
get new members and they were actively
trying to grow theosophy into a religion
and the elites loved it because it's
very new world order ecumenical
um it lends itself to having like a One
World Government so there were a lot of
Elites pushing theosophy and occult
ideas around this time too
it was very useful for getting people
whipped up into a revolutionary Panic as
well so what do you mean Elites like who
yeah who right
um it would be
powerful bloodline families that have
been around for centuries the banking
Elite you know some of these banking
families that have been around a long
time I know we're on YouTube so I'll be
kind of careful what I say but
um it would be basically the people who
control the institutions so if you look
at some of the biggest most powerful
universities media companies banking
um and these are people from all
different ethnic backgrounds it's not a
lot of people think it's one group it's
not
um there were British Elite there's
Elite in every nation so it's whoever
are the most rich powerful wealthy
people that control the institutions so
why would they want a revolution like
why would they want like why would they
want people in an uproar yeah there's a
a permanent state of Revolution and
Rebellion is really useful to these
people because it basically and this is
definitely what happened with feminism
people think these are like Grassroots
uh movements for human rights and things
like that and they almost never are I've
done some really really extensive
research on this and the reason they
love to keep people in a Perpetual state
of revolution is because then if you
want to change things if you want to
restructure Society you can co-opt these
movements and steer them the direction
that you want to go so in the book I
explain how it's not a coincidence that
the same people who funded the suffrage
movement are the same people who
instituted Central Banking the Federal
Reserve Act the income tax system even
the system that produced tax
withholdings those people were all like
really really active and popular because
they can sell them the solution yes yes
so what is the problem here like let me
sell you this is the policy we're trying
to pass so it helps them control people
because you say we're fighting against
this problem even though they know it's
not a real problem because we're happy
at home but they're like if we can
disrupt it convince them they have a
horrible life or whatever ever then we
can sell them this solution yes exactly
and so what did the elites get out of
feminism they got uh double the tax base
right because now you you can only tax
men before if you were going to
Institute an income tax like they did
around the turn of the century right
before suffrage you're only taxing maybe
30 percent of the population right if
you can get women out of the home and
into factories
um you can tax their income as well it
doubled the labor market so remember
this is right after the first Industrial
Revolution when everything has become
mechanized and these big Golden Age
wealthy people have railroads they're
trying to build they have factories
they're building all over the world and
it's a if you wanted a huge pool of
cheap labor get the women into the
workforce because at that time they're
unskilled they you're convincing them
that they must have their own money that
they're being oppressed by having to
stay home and raise kids and Obey men so
it's better for you even if if you have
to go slave for 12 hours a day in a
factory for a really low wage it's going
to give you this Independence and
they're kind of dangling this carrot so
it gave them a huge new pool of cheap
labor it gave them a whole new tax base
and it also gave them a new political
voting block to manipulate and women are
very easily propagandized
so if you are a politician and you are
this is around the time that Edward
Bernays and marketing and propaganda was
just being developed alongside the field
of psychology and they learned that
women are much more malleable much
easier to propagandize than men so
that's another reason why it's great to
have women voting because you put out a
sad story you know you you show some
kind of abuses or or something bad
that's happening you get women really
emotionally worked up and they're all
going to vote for whatever is going to
fix that they're going to vote for
security they're going to vote for
safety so the the people who were
powerful at the time had a lot of
different motivations to drag women out
of the home put them in factories and
put them in politics and use them kind
of for their propaganda purposes okay so
1800s
1700s it's a Mary Walston craft
she she's the the writer but it's like a
fringe movement it doesn't sound like it
was that popular it wasn't no it wasn't
mainstream yet at all
um she kind of kicked it off in the west
a little bit and then we see like the
1840s was a time where there's all these
uh experiments going on with socialism
which was kind of new at this time a lot
of Socialist Communist communes start
popping up in the United States and in
the west even in England quite a few of
them and a lot of those early like
communist utopian Cults they practiced a
lot of feminist stuff like they would
try gender swapping and I talk about
this in the book some historical
examples of these Cults getting together
and having very bizarre ideas about like
uh polyamorous marriage but having the
women be in charge and having the men
take care of children and some really
bizarre things that they tried because
communism again is another thing that
wants this equality everybody's the same
and everybody's equal and we're all
labor units you know like this these
kind of ideas uh go right along with
feminism so you'll see feminism always
wrapped up with communist socialist
ideology goddess worship and Witchcraft
and then all also veganism and
vegetarianism
okay and that also comes out of all
these religious and philosophical ideas
so basically you just had these
intellectual circles in the mid-1800s
and they start to get more and more
liberal with pushing women to the front
and having them be speakers and having
them be writers in the United States we
had Margaret Fuller who was probably the
first the first person writing that was
popular who talked about gender
abolition
so she she was part of the
transcendental club and felt like
communism and and Humanity moving to
into the new age we need equality we
need to get rid of gender ideas we need
to stop limiting Humanity with gender
roles so these ideas are pretty old this
is this idea of uh gender abolition
which sounds really new to most of us
like oh it only kind of popped up in the
last 10 years that actually comes out of
the 1840s there were already people
saying this yeah wow so and so when
women it got the right to vote was it
the late 1800s or early 1900s 1920 ish
in the United States it was 1920 in
England they kind of phased it in but
right around the same time so I'd say
around right around 1920. so I heard
that in the 1800s like they were like
the women's movement was planning an
associations and that they were actually
like no like they weren't known as a
peaceful movement at all like could you
tell me more about that sure yeah a lot
of women who were in the suffrage
movement were basically terrorists so
they would do bombings poisonings
assassinations they would um you know
burn down buildings put rocks through
storefronts
um and they would get arrested quite
often and put in prison and then they
would go on hunger strikes now this is
something that I hear all the time
because feminists who really hate me
will say you wouldn't even be allowed to
be on the internet talking right now if
it weren't for the brave women who came
before you and made up of that too yes
but the first female it doesn't make
sense because the first female
millionaire was like the she was in the
early 1900s or late 1800s
yes yeah yeah it was um that lady they
made the movie about you know what I'm
talking about yeah there's there were
actually a handful of them um and one of
the first one of the wealthiest women
who funded suffrage she's in the book
her name was Elva Vanderbilt Belmont
so she married into the Vanderbilt
family and got one of the first ever
divorces that wealthy people had in the
United States she got a ton of money out
of that divorce settlement and this was
she alleged that her spouse was cheating
got a divorce got a huge divorce
settlement inherited a bunch of
properties from this Man's family from a
Vanderbilt then she married his best
friend typical feminists kind of move
right marry the best friend who's also
wealthy he was from the Belmont family
and they were like bankers and financial
advisors to the wild again did she do it
again she did well he died oh so he
basically he drank himself to death
inside so she got yet another
inheritance and became I think she was
at the time the world's wealthiest woman
and so she she said after that she was
done with men and she was gonna dedicate
the rest of her life to feminism and the
suffrage movement and she funded most of
it so when these women would get put
prison for doing terrorist activities
she would bail them out she would put up
their bail money and get them out of
jail and help them reorganize get back
out there and continue doing this stuff
and again this is even at this time
we're talking turn of the century right
around 1900 1910s
um suffrage was still deeply unpopular
with women only about four percent of
women and all of the like straw polls
that they would do at the time or
um where they're doing like a survey to
ask women if they even want suffrage on
the ballot at that time from all the
data I could find it was about four
percent of women who were interested
they had much bigger membership in
anti-suffrage groups way more women
members than they had in Pro suffrage
groups
um and I'm working on another book right
now about what the anti-suffrage women
said because they put out a lot of
writings and pamphlets and political
tracks as well and they had really great
solid reasoning for not wanting the vote
that okay that was what switched my
opinion on voting because I always
thought there was like three waves of
them that's always what you hear right
there's three waves of feminism and like
the second and third were bad but the
first was good until I heard on like a
Crowder episode that like women didn't
want the right to vote so I was like
well why wouldn't they want that like
you know it's not like I'm like like
they had to have had a reason right
right so then I started looking at like
I started looking up some
anti-suffragette like writings and this
was writing how it was like the
breakdown of the family and how you're
supposed to like two are supposed to be
one flesh and I was like damn that's
kind of what happened it is what
happened I'm just saying this is going
to be the breakdown of the family this
can't happen I'm like well Dad like the
based woman like and so that's what I
realized it was it wasn't like what I
thought no it's definitely not what
anyone thinks we've all been sold like a
certain packaged version of feminism and
the reason for that because you might be
asking yourself okay there's the
mainline history of all this stuff that
everyone's kind of heard what makes me
think that Rachel has just like found
all this stuff that nobody else knows
well the reason is because in the in uh
the late 60s when the Ford foundation
and the Rockefeller Foundation literally
created women's studies that was not a
field of study until like 1970 they
created it for the purposes of
continuing this social engineering that
they were already working on and once
that happened and they gave tons of
funding to major universities to create
women's studies departments
um they basically became The Gatekeepers
of all the history so the Margaret
Sanger papers any any of the historical
collections that we have that would tell
you all of this information it is in the
libraries of the gender studies
departments at these huge universities
and the professors there kind of get to
gatekeep the information translate it
and package it and then give it to
students write books do things like so
they kind of disseminate the information
and they they literally come right out
and say that they do that from a
feminist standpoint because and here's
their reasoning they said well the real
history like the the the unbiased not
that there's ever truly unbiased history
but the the historical narrative that
existed before 1970 well that was
written by men so they're going to put a
patriarchal spin on it and we don't like
that so we're gonna rewrite it we're
gonna literally rewrite women's history
from the standpoint of the oppressed
woman and it's called standpoint
feminism and they're very upfront about
it they don't even deny doing that they
say yeah of course we took the history
and we rewrote it from the perspective
of the oppressed woman so from their
perspective so the story that everyone
has gotten is not anything close to what
really happened it's their version it's
through a feminist lens what they think
happened okay because that's what I
realized too because I started they're
all giving me flat because I was on a
stream once and I said you know all
these studies that come out I don't need
a study to tell me anything like like
and I what I mean is like I'll see
studies that say the sky isn't blue and
if I look up it'll say it's it's pink
and I'm like well I'm looking at it now
it's blue and what I realized is I think
there's a lot of studies like pushed out
by like feminism where like it's like
made in these universities and it's like
with their idea like there's something
with the level of studies where like the
quality has gone down and I don't know
how or why I'm not I'm not a big you
know academic like yeah but I'm just
like as an outsider looking in it's like
something's off you know you can just
like feel it like you could just I don't
know yeah if you have just like a little
bit of a if you're somebody like you
who's like well but I want to know
what's really going on here because what
you're telling me doesn't match up with
like the problems I'm seeing going on in
my culture right now like you're a young
woman who's trying to figure out dating
relationships marriage uh why is
marriage such a crumbling institution
why are all the children being raised by
a single month like what's what's at the
bottom of this what's going on here and
when you try to actually dig into the
history it's very difficult because they
gatekeep the history they they kind of
co-opted it and turned it into what they
want it to be for propaganda purposes so
that they can steer the the social
movements right they do this it's kind
of like the um black lives matter where
they'll rewrite the history there as
well what's that call like the 19th the
1815 project or something like that I
can't I can never remember the year but
it's basically where they'll kind of
rewrite history from the from the
perspective of the oppressed you know
black slave it's very similar to that
they just do it with women instead what
are they I don't know anything about the
1815 project what's that
um I think that's the wrong year but
it's it's basically a Marxist initiative
to rewrite American history
um because of course they claim it's
whitewashed it's written by the
oppressor it's written by white men so
it's not the right history we have to
rewrite it from the perspective of the
oppressed you know African slave and
that's the real history so they're
basically accusing Mainline history of
writing everything Tobias white men so
they're like well we can play that game
too and we're going to write the history
from the perspective of the oppressed
black man or in the case of feminists
we're going to rewrite history from the
perspective of an oppressed liberal
feminist no I actually I got into so
much trouble recently because I was
talking about I read because this was
another thing where I read the writings
of the people at the time and it was
really interesting so I used to um I
used to run um I used to be a big Runner
right I ran a marathon before don't ever
do it that's the worst decision I did
not you know some people finish and they
just feel so good I did it I felt
horrible I was like what did I what if I
what was I doing this for now okay when
I was running I would listen to
audiobooks and I listened to this book
of a former slave and a guy who
literally like he was he was born a
slave right and it was so interesting
because he like liked his owner
yeah and I was like what did he just say
he loved like and so then I read this
other project which was like 2 000 like
video accounts and some were horrible
but some weren't and I was just like
this is but it's like you can't say
those facts without people like freaking
out yes yeah exactly so the reason I
felt like I needed I need to do a book
is because everything I'm saying goes
counter to the mainstream narrative and
what people believe about what they
think's true about feminism this idea
that women were just super oppressed and
one day they had enough and they started
marching and they demanded the right to
vote and then they got the right to vote
and then they said we are not going to
stay in abusive marriages and we want no
fault divorce and you know like this is
what people think happened that that
women were just on this Quest For
Justice inequality and they were just
fighting the oppression that they lived
under for so long because they just
couldn't take it anymore and that's not
at all what we find if we go back and
read what women at the time were writing
about in fact
um to go back to this idea of feminism
being born from the occult a lot of
people don't know that a lot of the
prominent suffragettes from the late
1800s rewrote the first five books of
the Bible
with a feminist Spin and it's called the
women yeah it's called The Women's Bible
and you can still buy it right now on
Amazon it's by Elizabeth Katie Stanton
who was best friends with Susan B
Anthony Elizabeth Katie Stanton's
probably one of you know she's maybe the
number two most popular suffragist of
all time
um and she wrote this with 39 other
feminists and they said right in the
forward right in the beginning of the
book the introduction Elizabeth Katie
Stanton writes that
women will never have true Liberation
until we get rid of Christianity and
Christianity is patriarchal you know the
men are in charge
um it always you know has this world
view of women being mothers and being
you know like Mary was a pure virgin
right and uh it's always the men who are
the ministers and the clergy and the
Kings and things like this and so
um we have to she said it'd be great if
we could just get rid of the Bible if we
could just get rid of it that'd be my
first preference but it's too popular
it's the most popular book in print uh
millions of copies all over the world
it's been popular for a thousand years
so we can't get rid of it so what we
have to do then is change it to the
point that it's unrecognizable and she
she says that right in there the quotes
in my book as well so
from their perspective we have to do
away with and Destroy Christianity we
have to destroy the family because women
can't be truly liberated until we do
those two things so they rewrote the
Bible took all the patriarchal stuff out
they didn't like
um for instance they did not make any
reference to Eve being the one to eat
from the Tree of knowledge they made it
to where it was both Adam and Eve or
something like that like they took out
anything they felt was patriarchal yeah
and you know I felt like that I felt
like that that Bible tale I was like it
really showed us what happens when you
listen to women like we should not
part of the moral of that story is that
Adam was nowhere around the reason the
serpent went for Eve was because Adam
was not like keeping her under his watch
and protection somehow momentarily she
was on her own and he knew that the way
to get to the man was through the woman
and that is still very true to this day
and especially in politics the way they
get to the men is through the women and
in marketing the way they get to men is
through women so oh my gosh that's the
most red pill thing I've ever heard
that's so true even like in War Stories
like the way they get to like a powerful
rulers who the girl he's sleeping with
exactly yep oh my God okay so so 19 all
right you said this what is the scent
Seance table yes so that's that chapter
is about how all of these suffragettes
who are out marching and terrorizing and
trying to get the vote for women we're
also
um having seances and pretending to be
Spirit mediums some of them really
believed it some of them were total scam
artists like I talk about Victoria
Woodhull in the book and she was a
spirit medium who was also a complete
shyster literal snake oil salesman
um and she would pretend to be a spirit
medium and then um give people phony
cancer cures she would give them um
stock market information and this is a
really interesting story so somehow
Victoria Woodhull meets Cornelius
Vanderbilt one of the big you know men
Mega Rich Gilded Age millionaires one of
the biggest guys on Wall Street at the
time and she was an advocate of free
love and protection she wanted to make
uh you know sex outside of marriage
mainstream and acceptable and normal she
had a ring of Pursuits who were kind of
like spies for her so what she did by
hooking up with Cornelius Vanderbilt she
would have all of his all of her sleep
with a lot of the Wall Street Bankers
who were in those circles and get
information tale as old as time they say
prostitution is the world's oldest
profession but actually Espionage
probably goes right along with Brad very
often you will have escorts and process
be informants or intelligence agents so
that's what she did she got a bunch of
insider trading info through her
processing ring gave it to Cornelius
Vanderbilt and they took the stock
market for a ginormous amount of money I
don't even remember millions of dollars
in today's money hundreds of millions
maybe in the first stock market crash
they basically engineered the first
stock market crash and profited off of
it through the intelligence gathering
she did through her prostitution ring
um like okay okay that's wrong that's
absolutely wrong but I'm a little
impressed that's like kind of smart
crafty
I would not have thought like go get
inside and from it that's a smart plan
um okay so so what was is that what the
Seance table was yeah it was this um
phenomenon through the late 1800s when
spiritualism was very popular
spiritualism was like this religious
movement of talking to the dead
contacting ghosts and spirits
um house hauntings things like that
that's when that stuff became really
popular and so a lot of the suffragettes
would pretend to be Spirit mediums or
tarot card readers or fortune tellers
um in order to
do public speaking or like what Victoria
Woodhull was doing it was kind of a
grifty way to make money
um it was a way if you were kind of say
that you had gotten kind of kicked out
of the good graces of society for being
a loose woman you could still make a
living as like a spirit medium or a
tarot card reader or a fortune teller so
there's an old saying that goes there's
hardly a suffragette who did not sit
around the Seance table because it was
just it was so these are the women who
pushed suffrage was these women and
they're the ones who rewrote the Bible
yeah yeah in fact um one of the other
really popular suffragettes who helped
rewrite the Bible her name was Matilda
Joslin Gage and she was the inspiration
for the witches in The Wizard of Oz
because she was the Mother-in-law of
Frank L Baum who wrote The Wizard of Oz
and she he was they were very close and
she inspired him and so Glenda the Good
Witch came from Matilda Joslyn Gage
because she would teach Frank L Baum
that witchcraft really isn't that bad
it's just women fighting for for you
know power and it's just women fighting
oppression witchcraft is actually just
like based women fighting the patriarchy
right so that's actually where the good
the idea of the Good Witch and The
Wizard of Oz came from too so she was
into witchcraft many of them were
theosophists occultists
um some of them were in the Golden Dawn
like Aleister Crowley circles
um so yeah there was a lot of a lot of
occult practice going on in suffrage
circles and then that led to the
suffrage March yeah yep so
that's when they all decided to take to
the streets and start terrorizing and
protesting knowing that they had these
wealthy backers who would bail them out
of jail if they got arrested oh
oh and so that's when like that's why
they're seen as a terrorist group
because they had the the divorced lady
for a Victoria something right Victoria
Woodhull yes yeah who who was born Alpha
Vanderbilt Belmont yes she Vanderbilt
like the Serena Vanderbilt you know the
Gossip Girl anyone the Vanderbilt family
is this like ultra wealthy family
um like Anderson Cooper is from the
Vanderbilt family Gloria Vanderbilt the
designer
um so they were like a really wealthy
family of the time and yeah that's
that's why they were able to go out and
do terrorism and get her they were kind
of like feminist antifa they'd go out
and do a bunch of activists terrorism
get arrested and then just get bailed
right back out by wealthy backers who
would put him back out on the street to
continue doing what they were doing and
they and these are the same people that
funded the passage of the 19th Amendment
and again their reasoning is they're
better able to control people and sell
them a solution
and usually the solution involves more
control right okay
um what is the Golden Dawn theosophy the
Golden Dawn Co furry man sorry yeah
co-free masonry so the Golden Dawn was
an occult group in Europe it came to
America as well but it was really
popular in the UK
um and it was the it was like the
theosophical society and some hermetic
occultists of various different occult
flavors that were kind of blended into
one occult religion Aleister Crowley
came out of the Golden Dawn
um a lot of the other like popular
occultists the the guys who ended up
eventually founding um Scientology
originally came out of the Golden Dawn
as well and they were the one of the
this is another reason that occult
religion is so uh enticing to feminists
is because they can usually become
presidents of these organizations they
can become clergy in these organizations
um a lot of the feminists I talk about
in the book one of them was like a high
priestess in the Golden Dawn and she had
her own little cult within it that she
controlled and it she taught people how
to do sex magic and uh all kinds of
bizarre stuff so I've heard a feminist
you just a cult practice is very
enticing to feminists because it offers
power based on female sexuality wow yeah
no I had a girl in my show say she she
did a sex spell on someone like she
placed a spell on her next boy this girl
was crazy I was like you did what
you're connecting a lot of Dots here I'm
not even gonna
now now you said a brave A Brave New
World what's that about
so that the Brave New World is after
suffrage we're heading into the 1920s
and we go through this giant societal
change where if you think of the 1920s
you think of The Great Gatsby you think
of like flapper girls right this is the
first time women had short hair shorter
dresses they're going to parties they're
partying with the guys they're smoking
they're drinking
um it was kind of the first mini sexual
Revolution and this is around the time
that they started developing birth
control diaphragms and then later birth
control pills and I talked about
Margaret Sanger and her involvement in
the development of the birth control
pill and the establishment of Planned
Parenthood and that chapter was really
tough on me to write I had days where I
would be so mad
um or I would cry because a lot of it
was lies a lot of how they got you know
Planned Parenthood established in the
the United States how they got the birth
control pill created and marketed to
women they used a ton of Lies just so
much false information propaganda
marketing that wasn't true
um and in the book I talk a lot about it
so if you want the full story just go
ahead and and pick up a copy and read it
but basically they told this lie that
women all over were just getting
pregnant and they were having oh they
had 13 14 15 babies by the time they
were 20 and they were just dying in
childbirth and they made it sound like
this crisis like this um female Health
crisis wait and it's the same system
it's the same I I I feel it I think in
systems I don't know how to describe the
way I think but it's the same system of
using like something a horrible story to
control women right so what they would
say this is the horrible thing that's
happening we need abortion to be legal
yes so what you're referring to and when
you say you think in systems that's very
smart
um it's called the hegelian dialectic
and it's synthesis anti uh no thesis
antithesis synthesis so you create a
problem
you Market that there's a big problem
going on you get everybody upset and
worried about it then you present a
solution and then you integrate those
and then you are now in control and
steering Society in the way that you
want it to go and this is like a very
old very well practiced uh type of thing
that that people in power do all the
time and uh right around this time in
history they were really perfecting
marketing and propaganda and we had
radio which was a new medium it was the
first like social media really it was
the first like mass media uh thing that
we had was radio and
um you could say the printing press was
first but then radio was the next big
thing so this is in the 20s and the 30s
when people have radios we're in the
interwar period between World War one
and World War II and you have Margaret
Sanger kind of hand-picked by The
Establishment to be the face of these
things
um and they kind of used her as their
little propaganda lady because she had
been a nurse for a very short period of
time she was not
she really didn't have any credentials
of any kind other than she was willing
to do this work and she was pretty good
at public speaking and they could kind
of put her out there and and use her for
marketing well a lot of times there's
like Men Behind These movements but they
don't use women as a pawn absolutely
yeah definitely wow so it was like left
wing it would have been like left-wing
liberalizing type of men who were who
were really behind this and backing it
and she worked with all of the same
doctors who ended up being doctors in
the Nazi action T4 euthanasia program so
the birth control pill is deeply
entwined with Eugenics so is abortion
like medicalized abortion Planned
Parenthood the same people who were
pushing this and developing birth
control are the same ones who wanted
eugenics in Europe they wanted you know
racial hygiene they wanted to get rid of
anybody who you know was below a certain
IQ or had any sort of deformity or any
kind of in inheritable flaw that they
didn't like birth control is a big part
of this and then also this malthusian
idea of overpopulation which now has
been proven to be baloney we now are in
a birth rate crisis and we're suffering
a population collapse due to all these
things but at that time the narrative
they were pushing was you know this is
before total industrialization of food
when you still had more poverty and
hunger issues than we do now and they
would say there's not enough food for
all the people and if we don't do
something about the population there's
going to be way too many people and
we're going to have billions of people
starving to death so they're they're
saying this is terrible for women and
that childbirth and motherhood
destroys women's bodies it's unhealthy
it's killing them and it's enslaving
them women will never be free if they
have to just sit there and pop out
babies and this is when because I have
five kids people call me lovely things
like baby Factory
um you know say oh you don't know how to
do anything except sit there and pop out
babies and now you're trying to peddle
some crazy book
you know this is where you get these
ideas this is where the propaganda
starts where motherhood becomes negative
right they start associating a lot of
negative things with motherhood you're
overpopulating the planet you're
contributing to all the bad things in
society because there's too many people
and this is a problem and you need to
stop and you should have less kids um so
they create birth control and Market it
as a solution to these problems
um and same people involved it's the
Rockefeller Foundation funding all of
this stuff just like they did with
women's studies
so yeah that's the the Brave New World
is when they start really taking control
of reproduction in order to control
women and discourage motherhood and say
no you need to be a career woman so this
is when that propaganda really started
and you and I you're much younger than
me but both of us were raised with this
beat into our heads from the time we're
toddlers yeah that you've got to be a
career woman you have to have your own
money uh if you depend on a man all
these bad things could happen what if he
leaves you what if he cheats on you what
if he beats you up men are very
oppressive and violent you can't trust
them and you have to have your own money
and your own security
if you have all these kids oh you're
just a you're a victim and you're stuck
and you can't go anywhere and you can't
do anything so well and I interviewed I
interviewed someone
um yesterday or the day before
um he he wrote a book called the history
of sex and I was surprised to learn that
actually
um the women stopping having kids it's
matching with what you're saying started
in the 20s because I always thought like
the 60s was the beginning of like the
everyone always thinks that like the
sixth he said that was more of like the
accumulation of a lot of trends that
were already happening so he said in the
20s like before then women used to live
with their parents and then until they
got married and they would get married
younger but the 20s was when like that
was that was really the beginning of the
end yes the whole nuclear family which
kind of also lines up with like they're
not being waves of feminism
right exactly that I would totally agree
with him on that and in the East so in
like Russia and the the Communist Bloc
countries because the Bolsheviks in
Russia take over in 1917 and they're
pushing feminism as well but they use a
different strategy in Russia and the
Communist black countries in Eastern
Europe to push it so from a communist
perspective they're saying look if you
want to fight the bourgeoisie and
empower the worker you've got to get rid
of traditional marriage and families
because
property and wealth are passed down
through the patriarchal limit lineage so
if nobody knows who their dad is then
that takes away any incentive to build
cross-generational wealth to own
property to work your way up you know
from being a serf to being somebody who
has land and owns a business or things
so and this is so the people in power
can stay in power yes exactly so that
they they can be the ones who are the
landowners and control everybody and you
know they promise you Security in return
like oh we'll make sure all the workers
in the world are taken care of trust us
but they were the first to the first to
legalize in Russia and they had a
horrible woman who was in charge she's
she's the subject of book number two uh
her name was Alexandra colintai and she
was kind of like the Russian Margaret
Singer but much worse she made not only
legal in Russia in 1918 I believe 1919.
uh not only legal but paid for free up
until the day of birth in every Russian
Hospital
so what happened is within the span of
about 10 years in Russia they got to a
point where they had three abortions for
every one live birth and it was
decimating the population and they're
heading into World War II Stalin takes
power and he has to make abortion
illegal again because he said we're not
we're going to get completely invaded
and taken over because we just had World
War One in a famine and now we're not
having any babies like the birth rate
had just dropped rock with this this
free paid for and everywhere and then
they also took marriage out of the
church uh because you know they got they
basically decimated the Orthodox
Christian Church in Russia and turned uh
they kind of had the first no-fault
divorce they turned marriage into a
really flimsy legal contract that you
could kind of have it or not have it you
could break it and nobody cared
um
there they were kind of the first ones
to Institute
wait and so I just realized so another
way to decimate the patriarchy is to
give the kids to the woman yes
because if the woman gets the kids then
there's no like you can't have a
patriarchy when the women have all the
children right right and it takes away
every motivation men have to get ahead
in life you know the reason that men
accumulate resources is because they
want to get a good wife they want to
have a family they want to have kids to
pass everything down to if you rip that
away from them they don't really have
any motivation to do anything for
themselves they're then they're so then
in Russia it becomes you work for the
state
everything you're working toward in life
is for the state not for your spouse not
for your kids not for the future of your
family not for your grandkids
um so why would you want to own land why
would you want to have uh money saved up
that you can pass down to your children
if you don't even have any rights to
your own children you're not even sure
if they're yours right so in the 20s
they didn't have DNA tests and they
thought this was a great thing
um to to maybe not know who the dad was
of all these kids because the kids
belong to the state now
and and because they're pushing all the
women into Factory working out of the
home they had the first day care system
in Russia as well called crashes where
it was communal raising of children
um and it was like the philosophy they
had a whole family law code that they
rewrote where
um the idea was that you should have
babies but only to the extent that you
want to create new labors new laborers
for the state and Alexander kolentai
wrote that women should stop seeing
themselves as mothers and start seeing
themselves as labor units who can
produce more labor units
and oddly even though this is a
communist idea this is another thesis
antithesis synthesis situation where you
had capitalism in the west so you had
liberal feminism based on capitalism
here which is women should have bank
accounts women should own property women
should own companies and be CEOs and be
boss babes and then in Russia you have
women should devote themselves not to
their husband but to Lenin this was like
an actual slogan they had uh that Lenin
should be your true love and then later
Stalin right so don't have a husband
don't have a family devote yourself to
the Russian State and wed yourself to
Lenin and have babies so that there's
more soldiers and producers for the
state and now in modern times we're kind
of seeing a blending of those because
you have Marxism here in the west
blended with capitalism so we tell women
get educated go into a whole bunch of
debt early in your life build a career
all through your fertile years and then
later when you're 35 40 if you can find
a man and get pregnant then you can
think about that stuff so basically we
tell them to do it backwards
that's what the guy
um that wrote the the his name is damn
David Baker but he he wrote the the
history of sex was saying too was that
the biggest because I always thought
that the biggest impact on like women's
birth rates was fertility but he was
saying no that he thinks it's women
going into the workforce because I was
like thinking about him like when I was
18 19 I I certainly wasn't thinking of
having a family I was going to college
and right and a couple Generations ago
that's what women at 18 or 19 were they
they were thinking I want to get the
best while I'm in my Prime I want to get
the best husband I can for myself I want
to start having children with him and
build a family so that in my golden
years when I'm older I'll have people
who care about me people who will take
care of me I'll have security going into
my old age I'll have grandchildren
great-grandchildren things like that now
we tell them no you have to start
building your 401k and your Investment
Portfolio in your career during those
years don't be worried about family we
in fact we tell women that they are
losers that they are stupid that they
are silly if they have like what happens
when a girl gets pregnant at 18.
everybody around her goes oh her life's
over
just like oh she's gonna be a loser now
she's never gonna be anything this is
something that I heard too because I had
my first daughter when I was 20 and I
was always in like advanced classes and
like smartypants kids programs growing
up and things like that and I I didn't
like school because I figured out early
on that it was not for smart people and
that it wasn't about learning really
um so I didn't want to go to college by
the time I got College age and I had my
first daughter at 20 and I was like
shocked by how much I love being a mom I
was shocked because I was a tomboy and I
I was never like overly feminine really
but I wasn't a feminist I just wasn't
thinking politically I guess but I loved
being a mom were you were you with
Daddy's girl yeah yeah I was like I was
a really big tomboy too but I find it's
like usually the oldest girls in
families and they're like close with
their dads and like right now boy yeah
two boys I was close with my dad and
yeah yeah
but when I
my daughter and I was like I remember
going to drive her to daycare she's like
six weeks old and I'm supposed to go
back to my crap job that I don't care
about and I'm driving to daycare going
wait so I'm gonna take this tiny person
who depends on me for everything and I
can't think of anything but her and I
don't really want to do anything except
take care of her I'm gonna go drop her
off with some other lady pay that lady
half of what I'm gonna make today at a
job I don't care about so that she can
do the job I want to be doing and I
thought this is the dumbest system ever
who came up with this it seems really
inefficient it's really painful like the
baby is crying I'm crying and all the
women around me go you'll get used to it
you'll get used to it the baby you'll
get used to it and you'll get used to it
and I'm like but why what like this
seems really dumb why is it set up so
that I have to go back to work in order
to like live and you know so that's when
I really started questioning things but
those things are done intentionally now
so the average first of all women uh get
more degrees than men now which you
probably have heard a lot of these stats
but more degrees are earned by women
than men now the average woman graduates
from college with about thirty six
thousand dollars in debt
uh she makes an average of 40K a year in
the United States so that's not very
good for that much debt and then
um so what what are you looking at when
you're in your mid-20s well I have to
build my career so I have any hope of
paying off this debt which means I don't
have time for like getting married and
having kids and then to think about
taking time away from your career to
have children well you're not going to
be keeping up with your wages you're not
going to be considered relevant or up to
date in whatever field you're working in
so a lot of women just don't ever get
there they just they're told that to be
a good smart girl and to be successful
these are the steps you have to do and
you'd better have a career in your own
money first that's like a prerequisite
to having children but what you might
notice we don't ever fear Monger career
women about everything that could go
wrong being a career woman we do that to
mothers right we tell them all the
horrible things that might happen all
the regrets they might have but we don't
tell career woman oh what if you go into
a field that you decide you don't like
later or what if you earn a degree in a
field that becomes Obsolete and then you
can't find work and you have all this
debt what if you uh go to school to be a
violinist and then you break your hand
and can never play again like we don't
we don't fear Monger women to death
about all the things that can go wrong
if they choose career and and don't have
a family we only do it to women who
choose to have a family
and I think that that's silly because
now like I mean you talk to women all
the time that they get older they hit
the wall they're in their 40s they're
alone and they don't love their career
and they do wish that they had done
something different but now the time is
gone and they can't do anything about it
and I get letters emails and DMS from
women about this all the time they read
my book then they message me and they go
I got played I was fooled into this like
I totally fell for it and now I'm 40 or
50 or even one lady in her 60s and
they're like there's nothing I can do
about it now I'm just stuck with it I
would love to actually interview some of
them because it's really hard to find
women that admit it I know it's really
hard to find girls that actually like
will will tell the younger generation
don't do that yeah well and they'll
they'll write me an email because
they'll say I can't talk about this to
the people around me I can't tell my
parents or my friends that I have all
these regrets um and then I get letters
from younger women like I got one from a
girl who was in dental school to become
a dentist she was in like her last year
of dental school and she said you know I
I became Christian a couple years ago
and for the last two years all I can
think about is getting married and
having kids like that's really what I
want like down to my soul that's what I
really want most and I don't feel like I
can do that because I've invested all
this time and all this money my parents
will be disappointed and they won't
understand they will think that I've
gone crazy and lost my mind and that I'm
making a mistake and I just don't think
I can handle all the pressure from
everyone around me if I don't go like
leave college and start a dental
practice but she's saying to me if I
start this dental practice well it takes
years to build it and then once you've
built it are you what are you gonna do
just walk away from it like just dump it
to have kids so she just she felt so
stuck and this is a girl who's like 21
years old and she is in her prime and
it's because of the propaganda and how
we teach women about not only the
history of women and and their status in
life in society but what they should be
doing now and it's like
they're just hit with all of this
propaganda throughout their whole life
that to just I've heard this all the
time oh you're just a stay-at-home mom
because I stayed home for 12 years and
homeschooled too
and even some of the more conservative
women around me just thought that I was
nuts they were like you're gonna regret
it and it's a shame you never know it's
a shame you never did anything with your
life you know that kind of silliness
um no I just I've heard that like I grew
up in a pretty conservative like area
and I would I've even heard that oh
she's just I've heard that so many times
yeah yeah this idea that that you're not
doing anything with your life it's like
first of all when I have five kids do
you think I'm just sitting on the couch
all day what I mean what do you think
I'm doing you think I'm just laying on
the couch watching soap operas no I'm
I'm busier than most career women with
my five kids but now that they're older
my oldest is 22. my youngest is 11. I'm
so glad I put in all that hard work in
the front end of my life because now I'm
reaping all the benefits of it and as I
do get older I'm really looking forward
to grandkids to having a big family
um I'm not going to have to you know be
alone in my later years I'm gonna and my
kids keep me young and active and life
is great you know I have a great
marriage although feminists around the
world are constantly writing me to tell
me that they help you know my husband
dies in a fire and I'm left destitute or
they hope that he leaves me for a
younger woman and it's like so they see
you happy and married with kids and
they're angry and I'm like wait I
thought your life is awesome I thought
you loved being a boss why do you care
if I'm happily married with kids why do
you want that to be ripped away from me
if you're so happy right
what what happened during this sexual
Revolution so the sexual Revolution was
like a culmination of all the stuff
leading up to it where now we have
television and
strangely the CIA during the 60s decides
to get involved in the cultural
revolution in fact the CIA and other
intelligence agencies helped steer it
they were involved in a lot of the bands
and and movies like a lot of the pop
culture at the time a lot of people
don't know that a lot of the popular
hippie bands that all the Boomers were
listening to were CIA Creations there's
a really good book called weird scenes
inside the canyon about that and the CIA
also pushed feminism so they recruited
Gloria Steinem out of Smith college in
the 60s
um she was sponsored also by the Ford
Foundation they kind of worked together
with her and they kind of hand-picked
her again to be the new mouthpiece for
this new uh I wouldn't even call it a
wave because like you said it's like a
continuous wave it had different phases
right but in the 60s they they kind of
hand-picked her to push this
because of the people they had to choose
from they had like Betty Friedan who was
an older frumpier lady she wrote the
Feminine Mystique and that book did
pretty well but she wasn't exactly
someone you'd put on TV that the younger
generation wants to emulate but Steinem
had like highlights in her hair and she
you know they they actually had her work
at the Playboy Mansion doing some
Espionage there and so they'd put her in
like she was kind of cool for the time I
know that's weird to think about Gloria
Steinem being cool but in the 60s she
was kind of like a cool new woman they
always have different versions of the
new woman they had a new woman in the
1800s a new woman in the 20s and then a
new woman in the 60s and she kind of
helped really push feminism into the
mainstream using TV and magazines like
Ms magazine which was started with CIA
funding
um and making
normalized uh if you guys know anything
about the history of Roe v Wade Roe v
Wade was very re-engineered it was also
built on a bunch of Lies it was
not what we're told it is there was a
lot of shenanigans going on there so
there's just this another big push of
social engineering to tell women uh we
have gender studies now you can go to
college and you should go to college and
and women are oppressed by having to
stay in the home and you don't want to
be a Suburban housewife and this is when
they start marketing the Trope of the
Suburban housewife and this is so funny
because everybody has this weird idea
that 50s Housewives were miserable and
they were all on pills right they were
all on Mommy's little helper pills okay
well right now 25 of all adult American
women are on a cycle
so apparently liberating women and
shoving them into the career world uh
didn't fix that and I strongly question
the stats of every stay-at-home mom in
the 50s being on drugs that that wasn't
the case it was generally more like
entertainers and upper class people who
had access to doctors they could pay for
barbiturates who did that but even if
you believe that clearly that problem
didn't get solved so the sexual
Revolution was like the final push for
getting people to procreate as much as
possible outside of marriage because it
destroys pair bonding it ruins the
institution of marriage it does the same
thing it kind of did in Russia which is
a limit eliminate
um parentage through the man right if
men don't ever know or even if they're
just not certain that whoever they're
sleeping with the baby's going to be
theirs it just really takes away a lot
of the impetus for men to be productive
and gain things for themselves so it was
just another push for
um getting women into college getting
them into the workforce and between 1960
and 1980 the workforce doubled and it
was in large part due to women leaving
the home and going into the workforce
and mass for the first time yes they did
that a little bit during the wars but
after the wars were finished they would
go back home the 60s and 70s were the
first time that women left the house and
didn't come back and it gave them this
huge expanding tax space it expanded the
GDP and the economy which of course the
elites love to do
um and it it gave them a whole new way
to propagandize and and get more
participation from women in boating
because even after uh voting was you
know voting rights were given to women
it took a while to get women into voting
booths they still weren't super into it
and they had to use a lot of propaganda
to push women into voting booths too so
yeah it just was kind of that final push
to uh liberalize and get the sexuality
piece is so important it's so important
if you want
this atomized culture that we live in
now because like all the women that you
have on and that you talk to all the
time the girls who are on the whatever
podcast you know this uh thing we see
right now which is exciting to me of
these girls who are vapid like
empty-headed only thinking about their
Instagram likes only thinking about
their body count and their fake
eyelashes and their lip fillers and all
this stuff it creates this huge consumer
Market too that's another big thing yeah
so like right now eighty percent of all
consumer spending is controlled by women
right Boomer age women are gonna see
they're gonna be the first generation to
have a double windfall meaning when
their parents die they're probably gonna
inherit something and then they're
probably gonna outlive their spouse or
get divorced so they're gonna get money
from the spouse too so Boomer age women
have massive control over consumer
spending which is why almost all the
marketing is
what age is Boomer aged women would have
been 1948 so like the end of the war to
I believe 1970. okay and then Gen X
would be like 70 to like 80. so yeah
boom rage women post World War II born
in the late 40s 50s
and early 60s
okay so we have the sexual Revolution
um now women are leaving the home yeah
and then it says Pandora's Box returned
to god goddess yeah so what we did with
sex Liberation was kind of like opening
Pandora's Box if you're familiar with
that Greek myth or Roman myth
um of opening Pandora's Box and letting
things out you can't put them back in
like you can't put the toothpaste back
in the tube so now we've got this
liberated culture where women and and
the sexual Revolution the other big
thing I should mention about it is that
it broke the contract so I just
interviewed my grandma who's 97 on my
YouTube channel and I was talking to her
about what life was like when she was
young first I asked her if women like in
her Social Circles as a teen and in her
20s did women feel oppressed and she
said no we never did she was born in
1928 yeah 1928. so this is the 30s and
she's like no we we didn't think about
it that way at all we never felt
depressed and
asked her like what was it like courting
and trying to get married and and she's
explaining it as like yeah all of us
girls were hoping to get a nice fella
you know we want someone from a nice
family with a good reputation somebody
who has a good a good chance of
providing you know a good career ahead
of him or some kind of you know
Financial Security in his future someone
who we share our religious values with
and things like that uh now what we have
is not like that at all it's like hook
up culture it's body counts it's
um you know swiping on all the dating
apps and things like that I had I had a
realization with the the guy I
interviewed yesterday where he was
saying like when women have security
they go for looks
yeah so the problem is it's like when we
um when we have a job where we have
money we then go for looks well here's
the problem women find 80 of men
unattractive exactly so then you're all
going for the same 20 of men right and
so then it's going a little bit more
back towards polygamy until women hit
their like 31 is the average age of
first marriage in the UK then they go
back to me yeah yeah I think it's like
28 or 20 like the new numbers it's like
28 or 29 now for women and so then then
we go back to monogamy but like and then
we we go for the security but then it's
like the problem is the men and it's not
necessarily women's fault because we've
all been brainwashed for this it's like
when women are left to our own devices
we we don't pick for security which is
like when families were more involved
like security would be a bigger pick
right right it was very future oriented
you're thinking about the quality like
children you're thinking about your
grandchildren's futures you're thinking
very long term and now the thinking is
very short term because we broke the
social contract among women so a hundred
years ago when men are looking for
chaste Young
people to marry young women to marry who
they can have kids with right that's
what they're looking for they're looking
for youth Chastity
um and somebody who's like probably
agreeable wants to be a mother things
like that it has a good reputation then
it incentivized all the women to mostly
remain virgins till they got married not
that there weren't some who didn't but
it it was like a knock against you right
but I found it it was a virgin and it's
not like that 1920 they said 1920 it was
15 admitted to premarital sex so I was
like even let's just say the women are
liars even if we double it that's still
two out of three aren't or are our
virgins sorry right exactly right so
what happened when in the 60s when they
pushed the Counter Culture sexual
Revolution if you could just bump that
number up a little bit let's say 35 of
the women are willing to have sex before
marriage well they've ruined it for all
the rest of us right because now all the
men are just going to go to that 35
because they it it seemed like a good
deal to men I think now men are
realizing it wasn't but at the time it
was like wait I can just have sex and I
don't have to marry her first I don't
have to commit I don't have to provide I
don't have to have resources I can just
have sex that sounds awesome well it's
bad for most it's just a small
percentage of men that get to do that
anyway right right the other ones get to
pick up the pieces after
like that's more damage that's you know
like that's been through like that's
been passed around by the other guys and
then another guy gets her after and the
other and that's like when I learned
like we're starting to see a rise in
like male virginity yeah everything is
kind of going like this it's just
getting very skewed and bent in in the
wrong direction and I always say there's
only there's a reason why feminism never
took hold because as we just explained
these ideas are very old they've been
around forever but feminism couldn't
take hold until we had technology
because technology is what gives women
this illusion that they don't need men I
just debated a feminist
um a twitch streamer gal a month or two
ago and I asked her because she said
there's no difference between the
genders and women can do everything men
can do now and even and I said wait a
minute you don't think there's hard jobs
that only men do you don't think there's
like you know the guys who keep the
electrical grid going the guys who do
the oil rig drilling drilling all these
like difficult labor-intensive dangerous
jobs that men still only do and she's
like yeah women can do them because we
have like tools or whatever it's like
this we can do it too
um and I asked her okay so do you think
we could just have an all-female crew go
out in an ice storm and keep the power
grid up and she was like yeah why not
like she really didn't think that was a
problem and so it's technology like I
tell women all the time you get in your
car than a man designed and built and
that you take it to a man anytime it
breaks or it needs maintenance and you
drive on the roads that men created and
built to your office building that men
created and built and you go sit down at
your desk at your computer and if your
computer has any issues you call the IT
guy to come and fix your computer like
yes you do need men
you totally need men because they built
this Advanced world that you live in
that gives you the illusion that you're
independent if we had like some kind of
disaster where the power grid went down
and we didn't have all these modern
things there would be no such thing as
feminists every feminist would get on
her knees in front of the closest guy
who could provide and protect because
we'd be reset Back to Before technology
so it's it's really technology that
gives women this illusion that they
don't need men and yeah I get it like
you can go about your day and pay your
bills and you can make money off your
Instagram and you can have your career
and things like that but
we've seen that that doesn't solve the
problems and it hasn't made women
happier there's something called the
Paradox of female happiness where the
more liberated women are the more
miserable they seem to get the more they
rely on psych drugs the more they need
therapy the lonelier they report that
they are and they're living longer this
is the other thing like women are living
into their 80s regularly most of us do
and you are building your whole entire
life around this very limited portion of
time where you have a lot of sexual
power and you're not thinking at all
about what you're going to do in your
40s 50s 60s 70s right so these women age
out and then it's like oh I guess living
in my apartment and ordering doordash
with my cat isn't as awesome as I
thought it would be we all know those
stories of women who've hit the walls so
it's like not only that but now we're
seeing children being raised in homes
where no one's ever married uh you have
Mom's boyfriends coming and going you
have dads girlfriends coming and going
um and in those situations the instance
of childhood is far higher than when
children are living with both biological
parents not only is the instance of
child abuse higher it's more severe
anytime you have a non-biological parent
like an an adult who's not a bio parent
Living With Children the risk of abuse
goes way up and the severity of the
abuse goes way up and we never used to
have kids on antidepressants ADHD meds
all this kind of stuff it was considered
extremely rare prior to 1970 if you look
at the old dsms
it was extremely rare to have depressed
kids and things like that and now it's
super common well and you know what I
was thinking about we're almost
Outsourcing families because it's like
you know like what was a therapist
before you would talk to like because I
was thinking like women would have an
average of five kids a hundred years ago
so if you had a problem you would go to
your mother your father or one of your
siblings or one of your million cousins
because your dad like your mom and your
dad and then you all had a vested
interest in not letting that information
get out to the public where now it's
like some therapist will go to the Press
like the Kardashian therapy you know
yeah yeah and so it's like but you don't
want your sister to look too crazy
because then everyone's gonna associate
you with the crazy sister and you have a
vast interest to tell her the truth too
where the therapist is just going to
tell you what you want to hear because
my vested interest is for you to keep
coming back and paying them but I have a
vested interest in my family not looking
crazy to the world because then I look
crazy it's like what do they say the
Apple doesn't fall far from the I saw
like 1920s dating advice and the woman
like one of them to women was like don't
tell the guy if your mom's crazy wait
because then he'll be afraid that you're
gonna be crazy yeah and we're gonna have
a crazy mother-in-law yeah yeah and I
was thinking like in a way where a lot
of like new Industries is US Outsourcing
like families yeah well and this is the
other thing that's so insane to me that
I say to feminists in debates I do a lot
of online debates and um you know
they'll say well I should be able to
have a career and follow my dreams and
first of all all women think that
they're gonna have the high paying
office job with the corner window office
and they're going to be flying off to
Paris or New York to have power lunches
where they're gonna you know close the
deal and make all this money they think
they're going to have this exciting
career and if you look at careers for
women from 2020 and 1920 they're almost
exactly the same the only thing we did
was swap about Farm labor for HR work so
the vast majority of working women this
is what they do they're a waitress a
teacher a bookkeeper a retail worker a
nurse all the same stuff they did in the
home right nursing Child Care daycare
bookkeeping all the things you would
have done for your family but now you're
doing it for a corporation you're paying
taxes and you have to pay daycare if you
do want to have kids so then let's think
about daycare
you want independence you want to be
able to go have your career but what
about the woman you're paying to raise
your kids what about her independence
you're just swapping out one woman who's
the mother for a random other woman
who's not the mother and you think she
is gonna do as good a job as you would
do for 10 bucks an hour for kids that
don't belong to her what about all those
women so it's uh some of the Marxist
feminists do have a point when they
critique uh capitalist feminism because
they're like wait you're just SWAT it's
just very classist you just want to move
up a class and you don't care if these
lower class women have to take on all
the burden of childbearing and child
raising and and that is what happens so
it's like you've just swapped mom for
some other random lady and you're still
doing the same types of work in most
cases that you would have been doing if
you were in the home it's just that now
the corporation gets to profit off of
you and the government gets to take a
bunch of your income and you have to pay
out to daycare
we Outsource motherhood and and family
life you're exactly right what do you
what do you think of like because a lot
of women will say well I have to work
because you need two incomes to survive
today yeah feminism created that
situation we used to have men would have
a family wage in fact in pre-World War
II Germany they did have to put some
laws on the books to restrict mothers
from working outside the home and the
reason was because they found this huge
new labor pool of women was displacing
men and so men's employment in factories
because this is a very industrial and
agricultural economy still at the time
men were getting displaced so men's
unemployment was going up uh depression
and suicide among men was going up and
um their wages were going down so it was
also at that time in Germany depressing
the birth rate which they didn't want so
they had some laws on the books where if
you were married or if you were a mother
you weren't supposed to work for a
certain amount of time unless there
wasn't exception so we've created an
economy that is based on an individual
wage not a family wage because all of
them in your workplace right I never
thought it's based on an individual wage
instead of a family way I never thought
about it like that that's why in the
that's why in the 30s 40s 50s you could
have a man
a man who was a gen
ly with four kids and support them you
can't have that now because of what
doubling the market pool has done to
Wages that's why wages haven't gone
anywhere really since like the 70s that
we've had very depressed wages
and now also because we've pushed women
into Academia so much women are getting
most of the degrees they're earning more
so it's very hard to find a man who can
make more than you and support a whole
family and men don't have a lot of
incentive to do that you know so it's we
just that's what I was saying because
what do they get at the end of it and
like you know like because it's not like
they get they get like the average is in
the UK anyway it's a 31 year old
right well so you maybe get one or two
kids she's been doing God knows what the
last 10 years and the women will always
come at me I'm like look at there's
exceptions to every rule of course right
I know it's not not every woman but it's
like let's just like you know guys like
because because I'll I'll say you know
women in 2023 you know the Purity is
gone like let's just call somebody to
Spade like only 85 percent of us were
virgins on our wedding nights a hundred
years ago like you can't you can't say
that we bring like we don't bring that
anymore
no and then of course everybody's
familiar with the stats that women
initiate the vast majority of divorce
among college-educated couples it's even
higher and then the marriage failure
rate is very high in a lot of people
just aren't even bothering to get
married anymore at all the the rate of
marriage has gone down so it's like why
would they like to be honest I'm doing a
documentary on the court system in the
UK and I know it's similar in the U.S
it's like yeah I'm looking at it from a
guy's point of view like marriage isn't
marriage anymore it's not marriage if
you if it ends after eight years on
average right that's not me like
marriage is supposed to be we're stuck
together forever and there's nothing you
could do and guys could even get over
women like you know
um
you know I think men would honestly
accept the women not being as pure you
know not being as hot because we're
fatter like I think honestly if we
couldn't leave but it's like they'll get
but it's like they'll get into marriage
and then leave take the kids and take
all their money why would you do it and
right as far as they can't even avoid it
by not getting married because I spoke
to a divorce attorney and he's like you
know I could get married tomorrow
marriage does not scare me that's what
he told me he's like I'll get a prenup
it'll be fine what I'm afraid of is
children because when you have children
those are not your kids they're her kids
right and then you have no control over
what other scumbag men she's dragging
into the house like
that happened with my parents where my
mom left for no good reason she just
wanted a younger guy she found a younger
guy kicked my dad out of the house moved
to this younger person in who was closer
to my age than her age and my dad could
do nothing about it he had no rights
because this is the 80s and there's this
and the guy was creepy right so it's
like now there's this creeper dude in
the house with my dad's kids my dad's
fighting like with everything he's got
in the court system and they're just
like sorry and there's like nothing he
can do about it it's like Beyond
heartbreaking it's beyond horrible and
another thing that I like to talk about
when we're talking about feminism and
how the world that we've created with it
is that there was a natural balance of
power that people don't talk about prior
to feminism so throughout history yes
men have had the Monopoly on Force
um because they're physically bigger
stronger and prior to technology
especially they they did dominate in
that way however all throughout history
now that we have genetic studies we now
know that every living human being right
now has twice as many female ancestors
as they do male ancestors that's because
historically eighty percent of women
were able to reproduce because all you
had to do historically to reproduce was
be fertile for the most part right and
then only 40 percent of men ever got to
reproduce because even historically men
had to compete for women they had to
compete for mates and a lot of them died
in wars men are very Expendable they've
always been seen as very Expendable all
throughout history so only about 40
percent of men who've ever lived have
gotten the chance to reproduce so just
by that women have a huge genetic
Advantage we have a big advantage in
passing our genes on then you're looking
at men might have the Monopoly on you
know force and money and maybe like
government but women had tremendous
power prior to feminism because we're
generally The Gatekeepers of right we're
we're still women were still kind of the
choosers and The Gatekeepers of sex and
we get to select the mates and we have a
tremendous amount of power during our
fertile years we have a ton of influence
we had influence on the way children
were raised on the way Society was run
they were still the community organizers
if anything was happening you know with
Church Life School Life Community Life
historically women were doing those
things we were the caretakers and the
ones doing the nursing so we had a lot
of influence socially like we were still
the ones that were kind of running
social life for the most part now what
has happened is that we don't have
equality we have massive inequality so
now we see women dominating in family
courts that like we already met
mentioned they have the majority of
degrees now
they do better in school from the time
they're in preschool girls always do
better in school than boys do if a man
and a woman get convicted of the exact
same crime with the same circumstances
the woman usually gets 40 percent less
jail time they get less harsh
punishments in Criminal Courts they win
in family courts they control 80 percent
of consumer spending
and they're still the mate selectors
they are still this The Gatekeepers of
sex they're still the ones that get to
decide who procreates and they own the
children like you said so now what we
have is massive inequality where women
kind of control everything and have the
upper hand in everything and Society is
very gynocentric and men are still
Expendable they have less power than
ever less control than ever they can do
practically nothing to defend themselves
in a legal situation women are allowed
to be you know physically abusive and
it's very tolerated women can be
emotionally abusive and it's very
tolerated where if the same thing was
reversed and if have you ever seen like
a man whose woman is just like awful to
him and brow beats him and is
emotionally abusive and manipulative and
everyone just goes well he should stand
up for himself more but if the man does
that to the woman it's like oh he's a
monster he's horrible same thing if the
woman leaves the family like my mom did
if the mom takes off it's like well she
had to be happy don't you want her about
her reasons what was the reason
what did he do to deserve it but if the
man leaves nobody asks that they just go
oh he's a deadbeat he's a scumbag he's
an irresponsible POS right so it's we
don't have equality now what we have is
massive inequality
well and the other thing I got red
pilled on a this year
oh my gosh okay because when a girl said
she was I would just believe her you
know you know because when someone tells
you that you're like oh what happened
and you know um so when I started asking
like someone in my comments said no you
need to ask more questions because it's
kind of like awkward you know you don't
really want it but you know I'm me so I
was like all right I'll start asking
questions so so you know so I would
always add the next question I would ask
well did you press charges no did you
ever hit him well and so what I found
out is the majority of these women also
hit him so now you're just beating each
other because it doesn't make sense to
me if someone punches me in the face
and if a guy really wanted to kill you
like it wouldn't be that hard no so yeah
and so then I started like asking more
questions the craziest thing happened
okay
one day this girl keeps messaging me
plea because the stream I I did with her
right she um she said she I said like
you left him he wasn't abused like did
he hit the kid she said no great okay so
now later she keeps messaging me can you
take down that stream can you take down
that stream I don't take down streams
I'm going to tell you if you say
something and I value my time too much
if you say something crazy on one of my
streams no I paid my producer no that's
not happening I take down streams for
nobody just so you know see you seem
like a level-headed woman
no because if you don't want something
on the Internet don't say it on camera
right right but not all women have that
so then she so okay and I'm like this is
so weird she's messaging all these
people I know I just keep blocking her
because this is not I'm like goodbye
I'll never talk to you again now it
turns out I started doing the the the
court system thing and I find out that
women here are rewarded and I knew she
was going through like a custody thing
with their ex okay basically she started
making more money than him thought she
was better took the kids
and I knew that she that she said
something because that was why I asked
if he was because she said that her ex
can't see the kids and the kids are
better for it even the teachers say
they're better and but at the last time
like I was just kind of confused you
know if I had to do that again I would
have much more pointed questions let me
tell you but I'm I'm new to this I go to
the court documentary well they're
telling me that women get a free lawyer
if they accuse him
and you can go to Family Court and
accuse a guy that has no evidence and
basically this is how women are getting
custody of their children yeah well well
the wheels start turning
is this why this woman wants me to take
the stream down
because he wants to go to the lawyer now
I was like I'm Petty I'm a petty look at
I know we all have our our like you know
like the you know I struggle with
feminine I'm a tomboy all right I am a I
can be I can be a petty [__] I'm just
saying I'm like you are lucky I don't
find your case online you know like
John I have something to say
um
I might I think about it sometime like
if I maybe just find her ex and DM him
the video and be like hey girl that's
okay I have 7 000 videos I don't know if
he found you know what I mean right I
was like I will I'll do but but she
never said her last name so I was like
if I ever find it out I promise I'll
look
um nobody hopefully he'll find that out
yeah it's so true yeah publicly I want
all the women to know that come on my
show no I'm not taking the stream down
if you pull this on me I will send it if
I have the chance I'm not gonna go out
of my way you know but I I'll send it
don't don't tempt me I approve oh it's
just women women can just tear apart
families with impunity and with no
thought there's never any thought of
what it's doing to the kids what it's
doing to the man what it's doing to the
whole rest of the extended family
because divorces affect the whole entire
family
and women just feel so completely
Vindicated just I'm not happy I'm not
happy so I'm just gonna destroy and this
is something you see all the time where
it's like a woman will get divorced or
she'll kick her baby daddy to the curb
and then she'll lose 40 pounds she'll
put all this effort into herself she'll
go back to school she'll like do all
this self-improvement stuff and be like
I'm finding myself and I'm like
why didn't you do that before the
divorce because maybe the divorce
wouldn't have happened and maybe it
wouldn't have been so miserable if you
were on this self-improvement kick while
you were married
but no you're doing it because you're
hoping to attract a higher status guy
don't lie and say it's for uh I want to
be beautiful for myself no you are
getting lip fillers and losing weight
and getting a new pair of boobs and all
this other stuff because you're hoping
to level up from the last guy that you
just kicked out that's what you're doing
whereas if women were putting this kind
of effort into themselves into the
current marriage they have they might
find out it's awesome like my husband
and I say all the time because he's a
streamer too he's got like a popular
debate Channel and we talk about this
all the time that we trained each other
like when we got married we were both
good wives and good husbands aren't born
they're made like I had to kind of help
him learn how to be a good husband to me
and he had to help me learn how to be a
good wife to him and we put the effort
in together and worked on ourselves
together throughout the last 15 years 16
years we've been together that's what
you do and then you end up very happy
because you have this intact family
you've built something that's lasting
you do have the security and the
stability but it's still fun and
exciting and you still enjoy each other
so it totally can be done it's just that
we program women that the minute they're
having a bad day or if they don't feel
good about themselves it's got to be the
man you know you need a change you've
got to like get rid of him and go find
yourself you need to go uh Eat Pray Love
and do a bunch of traveling and sleeping
around to find yourself and then you'll
be happy and that's not the path to
happiness and you can see that because
these women are not happy and you know
I have to say all right it's I get a lot
of flack because I always come down on
the women you know but I have to say
like it is everything is women's fault
in society now why do I say this right
because you know when you look at the
numbers it's really hard to argue with
you know I I spoke and I do this just I
talk to people all I'm a talker you know
and so there's a homeless shelter down
the street from me and there's all these
crackheads and I I'm not you know I'm
like I'm so tired of the crackheads and
so you know I just decided to ask I was
like let me ask the guy who runs the
shelter I just have a question why why
are these like why are they in this
situation and he and I was curious my
first premise because I started to have
sympathy for homeless people because I
used to never have it because I just
felt like I'm a go-getter like you can
go get a jet why are you in this and I
had a couple relatives that were
homeless and knowing them it was really
the choices like one was homeless
because every person she lived with she
would Rob well now you're on the streets
because you stole from every family
member that took it you know so so I
that's my view I start doing the
documentary on the court system oh wow
so now I'm finding out that a lot of the
homeless men were wrecked in divorce
okay you know that humanizes it a little
bit so I go and I ask them
the homeless guy or the homeless shelter
guy he's ran the shelter for like 20 30
years my premise was maybe a lot of them
are divorced let me ask no not and he
says no not divorced I would say maybe
that I think he told me if he had to
guess like 20 roughly right still still
a significant number but not them for it
he told me the majority are people that
were in the care system from women with
multiple baby fathers and just broken
families so whose choice was that to
whose choice was that to ruin the family
the woman so now it's like we can
connect all these big problems in
society to choices that women are making
right at least the single childless
women ruin themselves now there's some
after effects on the whole system as a
whole right on you know whoever's got to
take care of you when you're old but you
know for the most part at least they go
be miserable by your own stuff however
the single mothers are the worst in my
opinion because they put their happiness
above I don't know protecting their kids
from abuse I I'm looking up all these
stats of single mothers which are worse
than single father homes yes um and and
it's like all of the things that like
the kids are more likely to do
a woman go to jail go to prison home
it's like 80 percent of all prison
inmates we're from single mother home
thinking about I'm like why would that
happen well because women were coddling
where the men they're disciplinary more
like right you know like I've seen my my
you know I've seen someone you know they
used to whip one of my sisters with a
spoon she kind of deserved it you know
when you still have that like oh no you
know well well that's the men need to be
there for to discipline the kids but
when you have all these young men
and then that have never been
disciplined in their life by a man they
go through among the crime right right
and then I'm finding out that all these
guys too they get played by the system
because they get preyed on by these
single mothers that need a sucker so
they find another guy that was raised by
a single mother to be the next
generation of Child Support yeah and so
I'm not even trying to hate on women I'm
just trying to say like okay this is
what happened when we got power yes
exactly right you know there's bad men
and there's bad women and I do think
women are more spiteful than men I think
we're a bit more emotional so it's like
when when if okay I I'm not a stealer
right I don't steal I'm not a stealer
but
if every day I watch everyone steal from
the Apple Store
and take a free iPhone every day and
there's no repercussions and they're
paraded and rewarded for it yeah you
know even me and I like to think I have
a strong moral compass even me I'm I'm
still human right I'm gonna still think
about taking that iPhone right you know
everyone else is doing it right it's
normal cheering them on and that you're
not going to jail for it why don't I do
it too and so that's what I realized
with the system that's built that's what
they're doing with women it's like it's
not necessarily that you know I do think
women are more spiteful than men but but
by and large it doesn't mean women are
horrible people but the systems we give
them make them horrible people because I
realize there's like a bailout I think
in systems so I'm like it's like a
system of bailouts because if the girls
have the debt they get bailed out by the
government it's like every bet if we
have we sleep around there's birth
control if we have a kid there's some
simp that'll which simps are a big
problem too like men raise their
standards and said you know what like
imagine okay if you had a kid outside of
wedlock or you you left the guy you made
a kid with uh which I'm finding out too
the single the deadbeat dad is a myth
because these men wanted to be in the
lives but the mom wouldn't let them like
a bunch of them anyway but but so I'm
like if the men said you know what no we
are not dating single mothers that's
your bed lie in it you're a harlot now
but the problem is they keep dating them
right so they and and I want to say oh
you'll never be taken seriously well
you're not going to be taken seriously
by the 20 percent of men but let's just
call a spade a spade 80 of men maybe
maybe it's 75 there's a percentage of
men that'll still take you and
especially young naive men right that
have no idea they're just you know
trotting along yeah they were raised by
a single mother so they're like yeah let
me try someone on my show and I was
telling him I'm like you are a single
childless man there is no reason you
should date a single mother and they're
like they're like fighting me and I'm
like no why would you want to do that
well I'll tell you why in a second but
the the last chapter of my book I go
over all these numbers I go over a ton
of stats and a ton of numbers because
like you I love those because they're
very hard to argue with and so the last
chapter of the book is basically let's
take a look at this last hundred years
of of feminism since it became the
dominant thing and let's assess you know
what we've gotten out of it and where
things stand and all the stuff we've
been talking about all these numbers we
know for certain that kids raised by
single moms are at higher risk for
everything everything from criminal
activity to addiction problems to mental
illness to Poverty any risk in life they
are more susceptible to being raised by
single mom and are there some single
moms who are single moms not by choice
yes at one time that was me my oldest
two their dad left it was not my choice
I try to do everything I could to
prevent it he was in a bad place with
himself and it happened we were really
young
but
most women that's not the case most
women are like my mother where it's just
like I'm bored or I'm unhappy I'm
unhappy with myself so I want someone
who makes me feel sexy I want someone
who makes me feel alive I want you know
somebody more entertaining or younger or
you know Mr Johnson next door makes me
feel sexy so sorry kids but Daddy has to
move out and you can never see him again
because at that point it becomes about
keeping the new guy right and having the
old guy around the new guy doesn't like
that it complicates matters and you have
to demonize the the X to justify why you
left so that's what always happens and
when you talk about men who defend this
stuff and defend dating single moms I
get the same thing I will get men who
come for me and are super angry with me
and take issue I had one that used to
follow me everywhere I went online and
like leave nastygram comments and say
awful things about me and of course it
turns out he was raised by a single mom
yeah and what happens is these boys who
are raised by single moms are always
told that sorry Little Johnny but your
childhood must be sacrificed for mommy's
happiness I'm sorry you have to spend
all day in daycare I'm sorry that you
only get to see your dad twice a month
if that if you're lucky I'm sorry you
don't like my new boyfriend who beats
you or treats you like crap or just
doesn't give a [__] about you I'm sorry
you've had to go through my succession
of multiple boyfriends that I've had
right so many kids are being raised with
oh mom's new boyfriend just moved in oh
six months later he's out and the new
boyfriend is in two months later and
there's this revolving door of strange
men coming and going their whole lives
so they're abused they're neglected or
they're just exposed to a lot of
dysfunctional gross behavior and
hypergamy from women so they think not
only do they think it's normal but they
defend it because they're protecting
their mother and this is like a huge
thing that I see with like more of the
SIM type of men every time I talk to
them and I can get to their life story
they're protecting their mom
have you oh my gosh you can hear it in
there okay I don't know about you I can
hear it in a guy's voice if he was
raised by a single mother and the way
they talk like I had a show
um yes yesterday that yesterday I get
all the days confused but there was
three guys on there and I could tell you
that two were raised by like in single
family homes or the other issue too and
I think this is like more prevalent in
like in in white communities to be
honest where it's like that yeah they're
married but the mom runs the whole show
we're like I think there's been like a
whole generation like where it's like
the the mother is like running
everything
yeah and where people have just never
seen a traditional relationship yeah and
I think a lot of that is because in the
go girl 80 80s and 90s like when I was
growing up and there's like Shira and
Madonna and Shania Twain and Oprah and
like all these strong women stuff starts
coming out what we saw in the sitcoms
because if you look at like sitcoms from
the 50s 60s 70s the dad is still the dad
and he like runs things and the mom is
like more traditional mom once you get
to the 80s and 90s it starts being like
The Simpsons or Everybody Loves Raymond
or all these different sitcoms where the
dad is a bumbling idiot who can't do
anything
um he's goofy he's silly uh he's always
getting himself into trouble and the mom
is the one who's like organized and
intelligent and thinking ahead and
responsible and she's always like
I don't know why I tolerate him he'd be
so lost without me and I am always
jumping in to rescue my silly husband
and it's so it's like uh they think that
that's normal too a lot of this comes
down to this propaganda of everything
being normalized and you see this now
with like uh the the female rappers
always talking about like sexually
dominating men right what's the big
Trend with like oh my gosh that goes
back to the goddess it does it does it's
like in fact cardi B's Instagram is like
a treasure Trove for me because she has
like pictures of herself dressed up in
like a devil costume where it says I do
the controlling like that was her
caption I do the control it's when she
broke up with offset for a while and
then he like begged her to come back and
she took him back it's this idea of like
I'm it's a matriarchy now like I'm the
boss [__] in charge and I'm the one who
says what's gonna happen and I dominate
you and you do what I let you do and I
mean my own mother that was her thing
the reason she wanted a younger guy she
picked somebody who was very like
impressionable and naive and easy to
control and I remember asking her like
when I got to my teen years being like
okay there was nothing wrong though we
had like a nice life and dad made good
money and he was faithful and he didn't
abuse you like what the hell what what
made you feel like it was fine to just
like tear the family apart and then
suddenly me and my sister are in daycare
all day long and and you're working and
we don't see our dad ever like what made
you think that that was like a good
trade and worth it and that you just had
the right to do that and she got super
angry and kind of like yelled at me and
was like because and she's talking about
her new husband who I don't want to say
his name but she was like because I tell
him what we're eating for dinner I tell
him what we're spending the money on he
doesn't have his political opinions I
tell him what his political opinions are
and who we're voting for right because
my mother went to University and got
very indoctrinated she ended up like
volunteering for Planned Parenthood in
the 70s and was like she still to this
day considers herself like a far left
Marxist feminist
and so if I gotta rip the family apart
to smash the patriarchy so be it you
know they don't care I would pay to
watch you debate her on live oh my gosh
that would be crazy I know you can't I
know how that stuff I know you can't do
that
but and I wouldn't do that to her like I
wouldn't
we don't talk we haven't talked for
years but I I wouldn't like put her out
there like that anyway but the the women
I do debate might as well be her because
it's the same ideology this doesn't come
from them it comes it's an ideology that
is fed to them that they then take on
this is what I've noticed like so how if
you don't mind how old are you I'm 42.
so I've noticed like yeah your
Generation
Um is like the divorce like the first
like generation that really got like
everyone's divorce the generation before
that separated right so that's the first
generation where like maybe they weren't
divorced and like maybe on paper they
were still married at death but that's
when like they started getting separated
but I've just noticed that like in the
generation before that seems to be more
based I don't really know like like that
was a little bit more traditional but it
was like almost and usually it's like
our like my generation's grandparents
are the last ones that were in
traditional relationships for your
generation it's like even if they're
together it's not traditional because
it's still this 50 50 she kind of runs
the like the show where it's like tough
because our generation like most of us
have never seen a traditional
relationship right I know and that's the
other reason that like when my husband
and I got together we had to like learn
this and figure it out together because
I I never wanted to be divorced or have
my kids grow up in a home without their
dad or that was never my choice I was
super against it
um I was willing I was like willing to
do whatever it took I would have stayed
forever uh it wouldn't have mattered but
the choice wasn't up to me at that point
so when I did get remarried it was like
okay I want a family and when I say a
family I'm talking about Generations
into the future the Wilson family our
kids and their kids and those kids kids
because
um for one thing if you think about when
they say you have to be successful you
have to have a career uh I've have I
have five kids I raised them at home I
homeschooled them they all the ones that
have grown up now are like thank God you
know they're like very thankful for that
and and they've said like wow we didn't
even know like how good we had it until
now we're adults and we're out in the
real world we see what other kids grew
up with and what it did to them now my
ones that are 20 and 22 are like wow
like thank you we didn't always get it
when we were kids but now we get it
um they're gonna grow up and get married
and have kids with stable homes who are
raised well that they're probably going
to be more stable
um less mental illness depression
substance abuse all those things and if
I have let's say I have 12 grandkids and
then those kids each have three kids
then I've got 36 great grandkids so the
ripple effect of my life and the choices
I've made as a mom are gonna go out into
the future and affect thousands of
people throughout the next few centuries
whereas if I just worked for a
corporation I would die and that would
be it they would just replace it and
that's it so I'm gonna have a whole
Legacy a whole ripple effect that goes
out into the future and affects the
whole world just because I chose to just
be a stay-at-home mom right well and
like I grew up so so I grew up it's kind
of a crazy story my mom had six like
biological kids I grew up with I was the
second out of six oldest girl between
two boys so it's telling you tomboys
it's always next to a boy and Daddy's
girl now um we had one kid my mom gave
up for adoption because her and my dad
got pregnant when she was like 17.
didn't meet him I was 22 and then they
adopted three teenagers like later so
it's it's interesting because when I was
a kid
um it's crazy I spent so much time
outside of the home just like because I
was in travel volleyball okay and I
don't know if you know anything about
travel volleyball but it's it's very
intense like I'm talking like you're
gone every other weekend
like out of state right so I grew up
with like nannies a lot because my
parents just couldn't keep up with like
all of like I had like five hours of
training after school and I and it's
weird because I'm in this weird like
looking back like you know you look back
and you have hindsight right and I
always think like you know I loved I
loved volleyball I was so passionate
about it but I'm thinking about it and
I'm like I really probably didn't spend
as much time with my family as I like I
think is good for a kid in hindsight
because I was always like the nanny was
always driving me around because you
know my parents had what are they
supposed to do they had six six kids we
all have to be in different places but
it's kind of interesting because before
like sports maybe was something you did
with your siblings or like the
neighborhood kids and you would like it
would bring you guys together but now
it's like it's gotten more competitive
and it's crazy because you know I
trained so hard I could play it like I'm
probably in the top like one or two
percent of talent or like of how far
I've taken volleyball but it's like you
know before you would do that and like
Bond as a family or like everyone you
know yeah yeah but it's like the
corporation or like when they
industrialize something it's almost like
it takes away from the family because
you know how am I supposed to spend a
ton of time with my parents when they're
they're telling me to go to you know
Vegas one weekend in Indianapolis
another you know yeah yeah well I think
that's another thing another thing that
affects birth rates and women's
willingness to be mothers is like you
were saying earlier when my grandmother
was having kids her sisters were all so
she stayed home her sisters stayed home
her mother was home the neighbor ladies
were all home all the women were home
all the women were having babies so they
would help each other like if one lady
in the neighborhood had a newborn
everybody would be coming to help and
cooking meals and your sister would come
stay or your mother would come stay you
had all this support and you had all
this help and for me personally trying
to do this and be a stay-at-home mom
with five kids I had no help because my
mom didn't want anything to do with it
my sister's a career woman my friends
are all career women everyone around me
is a career woman I'm like one of the
very few around who is at home with kids
so there was no one to help me and I had
no Community I had no camaraderie no
like bonding with other women because
they were all often cubicles doing
career woman stuff right so I think that
that makes it hard on women too whereas
if we had that kind of support and
Community now I think so many more women
would do it yeah well and I also
realized that like Vol because I just
started looking you know it's kind of
weird once you start getting red pills
on the world it's like I started looking
I started looking at like the volleyball
like it like the volleyball
um industry right because it really is
it's really it's crazy because it's you
don't make money at it as a sport so the
women that do it really really love it
right and I was one of them like I I I
still am like you know you can hear it
in my voice it's so fun but what I
realized is like the girls that like
take it to the highest level they're all
by themselves yeah and that's what I
realized all the girls coaching like one
of my coaches is like she's a feminist
and she's and I really like her like
she's genuinely like such a nice girl or
woman right you know but she's she's
older but I'm like she's in her 40s and
50s and she's got no kids and no family
and she's a really successful coach and
then I realized I was like oh [__] my my
coach in college was the same thing yeah
she was in her 40s and fit and I'm like
oh wow so was her assistant coach
oh like everybody involved in this right
I like that takes it to the highest
level yeah it's by themselves and I was
like wow I didn't realize that like a
lot of these like industries that were
pushing women into it's like one and
then I found out too like with women's
sports
um it makes you more masculine yeah
because it raises your testosterone so I
felt like my whole life
um I never fit in with like other women
because I was just such a top like
nothing interested me like even me
wearing like dresses now my son like I'm
just not a you know but but I was like
wow so like the reason I wasn't into all
the girly stuff was literally probably I
haven't gotten it tested because I just
found this out like a week ago but I was
like it's probably because I had high
like testosterone that could be I mean
I've been super into weightlifting for
like 16 years A lot of times like people
on the internet will be like she's fat
and I'm like no I have big shoulders
because I've been lifting weights for 15
years even you even lifting weights it
does that too yeah it does and I think
well like I've always been a little bit
more rational for a woman like more
rational more practical and more of a
tomboy and same thing as with you where
it's like the ladies around me would be
like wanting to go window shopping and
I'm like wait we're gonna just go to the
mall shopping I hate shopping too I like
if I ever make millions that'll be the
first thing I Outsource is have somebody
go do the job that's exactly what I did
when the YouTube every every outfit I
pick I'm like I just have I just have my
PA dude because I literally I hate
shopping I hate it yeah and like
Tupperware parties or Pampered Chef
parties I was like nope not I'm not
doing those
um just like a lot of that stuff I've
had a little bit of trouble with that
too although since I started writing and
doing all this I've met some really cool
women and made really great friends so
it's cool to know there's other like
based red pilled ladies out there who
get it and who don't just think of
everything from like but what about me
but what about me like when you say you
think in systems the reason you're able
you're able to like take yourself out of
it and look at stuff and look at what's
going on and say well this doesn't make
sense because you're not filtering
everything first through this me filter
of like but what about me which is what
I think most women especially younger
women today do it's all about me and how
it affects me and what about me and what
about what I want it's like there's
bigger things in life than just you and
just what you want for one you know and
some stuff I honestly was I wasn't crazy
triggered but I was triggered by a
little bit like when men were like
there's no reason to get married today I
was like what but my parents are married
like I was like I don't know what but
then I want to be married you know yeah
yeah but then you look at it from the
men's point of view and it's like well
that was my sister I don't know if I
would sign up like to I'm just calling a
spay to Spade you know
um I think I want to hear what you think
of this idea I think men should get
primary custody off the bat
yeah because I think that if women
because two reasons right I think it
really helps everybody involved okay I
think that the parent that can afford
the kids
should keep the kids they can afford the
kids right usually the man second of all
I think that if women leave they don't
get a reward
right they get the reward of like the
chill they always and they act like it's
a punishment they're like I have to have
the kids no you well then sign them over
to your baby but they're not gonna do
that they're not gonna do that
especially because they won't get the
child support and everything else and
they won't have the control
um but you would see a hell of a lot
less divorce I tell you that it would
totally disincentivize divorce in the
first place and in all honesty I was
thinking about this I'm like let's say
like the worst happened he leaves you
for a younger woman okay you're sad he
took the guy that was horrible but but I
was like honestly if he had the kids to
be honest you probably have a better
shot at getting remarried
that's you know in all honesty like but
I was like in honest I think the lever
should be punished I think whoever's
leaving the other person should get the
kids well that's basically what it was
before I think we should get I
absolutely always advocate for getting
rid of no fault divorce I think you
should have to have some kind of just
cause now I'm an Orthodox Christian and
in our church we do have some exceptions
we're not exactly like the Roman
Catholics
um who are like no divorce ever no
matter what even if you're getting the
crap beat out of you on the regular
um but we're not like Protestants either
who are tend to be much more liberal
about divorce we're like okay in cases
of abuse real abuse not like he was mean
to me or he won't let me spend five
thousand dollars at Hobby Lobby every
month um real abuse like in cases of
abuse abandonment or like addiction that
is so severe that it's endangering the
rest of the family like say your
husband's got like a crippling meth
addiction and there's right bikers
coming here
we can let you divorce your meth heads
like we can so there are exceptions but
they are like it has to be that you've
done everything you can possibly do
working with your priest and with your
family to try to rectify the situation
first and it has to be a serious thing
in order for a divorce to be granted and
then even then like remarriage has to be
under certain circumstances it's just
not this flimsy thing where just women
can because right now like I say women
can wake up and just be like my husband
doesn't make me feel sexy anymore so I'm
getting divorced and it's like that
should never be a good enough reason to
take a bulldozer to your children's
lives have you ever seen these SOB
stories
okay these like oh he I saw this one
that was like I was dancing on a bar and
he told me to get down and he just
didn't support me it was my birthday and
I'm like what the
F maybe maybe you're acting like a hoe
Diane like get off the bar table exactly
well this is the thing that I always say
too is that now the way because of the
propaganda
women today think that a man having any
kind of boundaries any kind of
self-respect or just telling a woman no
that's abuse now
so you'll see these women that they're
like in a marriage and they'll be like
but I want a new car every year and I
want a vacation every year or I want to
do this crazy thing that's probably
really bad for the family and just the
man saying listen Diane but no no Diane
that's not that's abuse now a man
telling a woman no having a boundary of
any kind or saying uh no you're being
disrespectful to me and I'm not going to
allow it that is now considered abuse by
most women and that's where all this
like men are abusive men are abusive men
are abusive it's because basically if
you tell a woman no you're an abuser now
and that's absurd and that needs to end
too because yeah women feel fine
punching the crap out of a guy they
think they're allowed to lay hands on
men they think they're allowed to
um I see this all the time women shaming
their man in public
like they'll be at dinner and like say
something to the waitress like mocking
their husband or like you know putting
him down or making fun of him or putting
him down in front of family and friends
and women need love but men really need
respect they need to feel respected and
they need to feel needed and so when
you're constantly this is like most
women now love to just cut their man off
at the knees constantly and they think
that's fine they don't think there's
anything wrong with it they think it's
cute they think it's funny no I've
definitely because in my whenever I grew
up my my siblings and I just roast each
other like literally yeah it's just like
like how I grew up and when I was in
um a relationship that's what I realized
that I would do because I was so used to
it yeah
it is something I had to like train
myself out of because I was like oh no
you can't like men don't see it like
that like it's like really disrespect
like it's one thing when it's you know
your your sister or whatever like that's
but that's and that's what I mean yeah
it's like that's what I realized that
men like see respect as love and it's
funny it actually helped me with one of
my brothers like he's just a really like
dominant personality and when we were
younger like me and him just butt heads
all the time you know he's my little
brother I don't listen to him like
but what I realized is like the second I
started like because one day I just woke
up and I was like Adam is actually a
really hard worker he's actually really
smart and I was like you know what if I
had to bet on one of my siblings being
like a really rich like like super
successful I'm like I would probably bet
on Adam and I was like maybe I should
like take his advice and all of my other
sisters did not get along with Adam
because again he's the one bossing
everyone around telling everyone today
everyone's annoyed and then one day I
just started saying you know what Adam
like what do you you know and like
actually like listening to him and it
was crazy I went with fight from
fighting with him all the time to like
I'm probably closer with him than any of
my other siblings now and I was in
that's what I realized like when you
respect a guy's opinion it's like that's
like the ultimate form of love to them
yeah and that's really all they want
like I saw you had
um what's the fellow you just had on it
was on last night it was like Jay wall
Waller yeah Justin Waller yeah yeah he
was talking about that how like if you
are a hard-working guy and you're really
successful and you're doing all this for
your wife or your girlfriend and you
take her on a vacation or do something
special with her really all the men want
to hear is like wow I really appreciate
that I see that you put in all this
effort and did all of this and I really
appreciate it and thank you and I
respect you like if you just do that
like 99 of men are gonna treat you like
gold they're gonna stick around forever
they're going to be great dads men don't
need that much if we are just
kind and respectful to them and not
constantly cutting them off at the knees
they're they're great like my husband
same thing when we first got together I
had bad habits like that too
um and we still roast each other like in
private for fun because we're we're both
like that a little bit but I never do it
in public because when we first got
together I would kind of do that not
same thing I wasn't trying to be awful
to him or anything but I just realized
the impact it had and early on in our
dating he told me that he was like look
if this is how you behave like I don't
want to date you and at first I was
really mad at first I was like
and then it took me about two minutes to
be like wait do I want to be that person
do I want to be the girl who like throws
stuff at him and has a snotty sarcastic
comment for everything he says like no
and then I realized like I had picked
that up from you know my mom and from
other people I was around and got that
under control and it's like did wonders
for the relationship and still to this
day if I just am like decent to him and
respectful he's the best husband and dad
that I could ever want so it's not that
hard but we make it super hard and I
think it's because everything caters to
women and women's feelings and it's like
it must be that the problems with the
man and the man has to understand the
woman and he has to think about her and
how it impacts her and a lot of men will
try to talk about something that bothers
them or a problem they have and the
their wife will take it and make it
about her you know my husband says that
too that like he feels like he sees that
a lot with his friends like his friend
will say oh I'm having a really hard
time and struggling at work and the wife
will immediately make it about like well
now I'm worried what if you lose your
job and what if we can't afford things
and now now I'm worried and it's my
problem and you really ends up having to
comfort her you know do you ever have
this problem where girls will tell you
their relationship problems and you
don't agree with them because it's just
like like I have this one friend she's
uh she's dating it like a YouTuber right
and she's always like whining to me
about the stuff he has to do for work
and I'm just like you knew that when you
started dating him right I got no
sympathy like I I told you we both know
that's another thing women do all the
time they all think they want the alpha
right they think they want the really
successful guy that makes six figures
and is six feet tall and has six pack
abs but what they don't realize most
women don't actually want that because
those kind of men they don't have a lot
of time to give you attention it's not
going to be about you you're not going
to get a ton of his time you're not
going to have a date night every single
week he's not going to be constantly
telling you you're pretty he's going to
be busy he's going to be focused he's
going to have a ton of Demands on his
time and attention and you're going to
have to be like my husband's this way
he's very successful very busy guy and
if I wasn't a person who's pretty like
self-sufficient happy to be at home
doing my own thing and like I understand
he's busy I respect that he's busy and
for years he had to work like 70 hour
weeks so I could stay home right and so
what am I going to do complain that I
don't get enough attention or complain
that he's not home enough that's not
gonna work so if you were a girl who
that's your priority you want lots of
attention from a man and you want him to
focus on you you'd be better off with
the type of guy who maybe just works a
40-hour week somewhere and makes an okay
living and you're never gonna have a ton
of money but he'll like build you a deck
on the back of the house because he
knows you like like it or he'll you know
make you stuff and build you things and
Dot on you a little more but don't be
going for like Ultra successful Alpha
types if you need attention and time
because you're not going to get it from
them yeah and like a lot of times like
you know when I look at my parents I'm
like my my dad was gone a lot growing up
so I'm just like I don't think I'm like
I don't think you women nowadays could
be faithful like my mom wasn't like that
you know what I mean like right I'm like
and that's oh my gosh I have this
controversial opinion everyone was
hating on me on Twitter I don't think
I'm like okay cheating is not okay I'd
like to I don't advocate for cheating
but why do we act like it's something
you can't work through
and I mean this mostly women okay
because let's just be honest cheating
for men and women is different
yeah men detach a lot more and we don't
really talk about the men's side why did
he cheat well you've been nagging on him
every day
you don't appreciate him you you you you
don't sleep with him ever yeah
and you're crying and whining and oh
what's the worst thing like it's not
something you could ever work through
and I just don't believe that because at
the end of the day it's not about you
anymore
and I really think that if you can you
should be you should and I even say that
even to the men honestly and I know the
the men don't like it when I say this
but but it's like if you can for your
kids I I think the kids are first like
what did the five-year-old do right
exactly in this so it's like you can put
your feelings aside you know if you got
to cheat bad sorry
but like if they're a Serial cheater you
know I don't but like keep the kids out
of it you know keep like why did the kid
have to be you know and I don't and the
other thing is like sticking it out for
the kids is not a bad thing because I
don't think it is either and but arguing
in front of your kids and making them a
part of your problem is so if you can't
learn you get along maybe it would be
better if you could just learn to get
along right well that's the thing like
so when I told a couple people I was
going to be doing the show with you that
was the number one thing everybody said
they're like are you gonna give her
pushback about her cheating opinions and
honestly I hadn't heard like I was like
because they would send me like the
tiniest sound bite of you saying
something I'm like yeah but I need more
context I'm guessing there's more
context someone asked me on a show if I
would accept cheating I don't wish to be
cheated on but I said you're the right
guy I mean let's just call a spade a
spade if you're with the guy that you
don't think is replaceable and you have
children with him
yeah I'm sorry I'm in it like I I I'd
figure it out I liked it you don't know
until you're in it right but it's like
it for the kids the children let's just
yeah well that's something that's gonna
get me in trouble and don't don't feel
bad because everyone's always mad at me
too and everybody's I'm always in
trouble as well uh and I would agree
that if there's kids involved yes you
should make every single effort to work
through it and this is again where if we
had community and people were in church
and things like that men didn't just
like maybe the top percent maybe those
really tippy top Elite guys could get
away with that but for most men it was
like you would get ostracized from work
from Community from your friend group if
you were known to be like a Serial
cheater like companies wouldn't want to
hire you because it brings a lot of
drama and you're not reliable and you're
not trustworthy it used to be more
stigmatized by the community and
um that gave a lot a lot of people a way
to work through like if there was an
affair you could work through it because
it was like oh if this gets out it's not
going to be good for you so if we still
had Community there would be less
cheating and if it did happen it would
be something people had to work through
maybe your priest would be helping or
your family would be helping to sort out
what went on but I do think what you
said about men and women cheating is it
is different they do it for different
reasons women it's usually like
emotional and like I want to be paid
attention to and guys who want to get
married women in the sack they blow a
lot of smoke up their ass and tell them
all the things they want to hear they
give them all the attention and glorify
and worship them and all that stuff and
so I think women do it for that reason
and Men the number one thing I hear from
men if they do have affairs it's be
they're like look I didn't want to but
she hasn't slept with me in like eight
years
like after after our second kid she just
wouldn't anymore and I haven't you know
I can't just go the rest of my life
never having sex like I didn't get
married for that and that's a really
common thing I hear and I've gotten in
trouble for saying I think if you're
married uh I don't really believe in
marital because I think that you should
be being generous and that you belong to
your husband he belongs to you too but
you certainly belong to him and you
can't tell a man okay I want you to
sleep with no one but me for the rest of
your life but then I'm not gonna put out
you can't do that to me that's abuse I
think that's abusive and if a man is
having an affair for that reason it's
been like a year and you haven't slept
with him
that's your fault and I know everyone's
gonna hear me say that and I'm going to
get a whole bunch of nasty DMS but I
think that that's true and the other
thing here's the other thing that
irritates me when girls all right
you go after a guy you know is a cheater
now how do you know he's a cheater let's
just
oh come on he's the top 10 percent of
looks like like and he had a girlfriend
when you got with him how often do you
see that he had a girlfriend when you
got with him but now that he's with you
you're expecting he won't cheat yeah
you're right yeah and so I just don't
like people like they get mad because
I'm like look it like let's Okay the top
15 like most of societies have been
monogamous they have like but the top 15
percent of men have not yeah so so we
still have monogamous Roots so it's like
you know I I'm not saying that doesn't
happen because my dad didn't cheat but
my dad didn't grow up in a world we're
we're throwing themselves at him like
they're you know the the athletes
nowadays like Jason Derulo that got so
much trouble for Jason Derulo's baby
mama or whatever was trying to expose
him for cheating and my like and the
thing is you have to understand men at
that level the women are trying to
figure out how to get them to cheat on
their wives there's women that go to
basketball games football games figure
out where the players are chase them
like there's a woman who literally would
try like her goal was to get the married
men to cheat and to say that a good man
couldn't fall like and that's what they
say oh they just falled into some well
come on he's got a 21 year old that's in
the top 10 percent of beauty even a good
guy yeah that's true that's true that's
the realization I had with my dad where
I'm like you know what my dad isn't
really in those circles whatever but if
he was in even the best men I know if
they are in a job like that they're
human like yeah well so like my husband
when he was working full-time as an
engineer in this big Factory there were
all these women assembly line workers
that would try to like like they would
come up to him seeing him eat his lunch
and be like oh I forgot my lunch money
today could you buy me lunch just one
time and I'll pay you back like trying
to talk to him trying to sit with him
and he would be like no offense I have a
policy that I don't talk to women at
work I don't eat lunch with them I'm not
gonna buy you I'm sorry you don't have
lunch but no
um and they would get mad and like
offended but he's like I can see what
they do they don't want to like date the
other assembly line worker guys because
they don't make much but they know that
all of us guys in engineering make good
money and a lot of them are single moms
and that's why they're working in a
factory so they're gonna try to weasel
their way in even if they know you're
married they're gonna try to like wiggle
in there and try to compromise you or
something like that and the other thing
they can do is even if he's just seen
talking to them or going to get a lunch
with them or anything like that they can
then accuse him of something and it
becomes her word against theirs and his
job is in Jeopardy his marriage is in
Jeopardy his reputations in Jeopardy he
can accuse her her she can accuse him of
assault so he basically does the Mike
Pence rule he's like I don't answer DMS
from women I don't have meetings with
women I don't do lunch with me unless my
wife is there or it's like a full-on
group setting I don't do it it's too
risky I'm not gonna put myself at risk
like that and now that he's got a
successful YouTube show I mean there's
been people
who don't like him who want his channel
canceled they will send thoughts to try
to get in his DMS and see if he'll reply
so they can then expose him or tell me
or something so it's like yeah men do
especially the more successful they are
they have like armies of hoes coming for
them all the time and my whole point was
just like I didn't say do it like I
think that's no he does it but I'm
saying like we can't we have some Grace
like do we have some Grace and
understanding for the opposite gender
where it's like a lot of the women have
okay like if you agree that you know
attention is to women as Sexes to men
which I think I do okay well what about
your open Instagram it's funny because
when you get into a relationship men are
expected to stop having sex but women
aren't expected to close all their
social media right but pictures off of
Instagram
so it's just like we can't have a little
bit of understanding
it can't be worked through and I and I
have an example of someone I know who
they're they're um their dad was a
Serial cheater he cheated all the time
but one day you know and she stayed with
him through it and everyone called her
crazy and one I mean maybe he didn't
stop and he just got better at it I
don't know but what like when when she
passed away she was still married and
she died with her husband and they in
the last 10 15 years of her life she had
a great marriage so was it better for
her to die alone was that the better
option for her yeah and break up the
whole family
yeah he died with her three kids and her
husband like yeah but women we train
women that life should be like they
should get everything they want and that
they can have it all and that their they
should never settle girl never settle
right so we give them this idea that if
the minute anything is wrong the minute
a man doesn't live up to his vows or his
expectations like just get rid of him
and go to the next one there's always
going to be another one to swipe to and
there's a whole bunch of reasons why
that's a bad idea but you're right we
have a totally different standard for
men than for women and like when you
were saying these girls get married and
they're not taking their booty pics off
of Instagram they don't and then if
their husband said look we're married
now you can't put up pictures unless you
are covered that's considered abuse he's
oppressing her he's abusing her he's
controlling right you how many and she
can go to Family Court and they'll log
it as abuse they will how many how many
videos have you seen were some girl
she's doing her breakup video and she's
talking about her ex and it's like he
wouldn't even let me go to the beach in
a thong so obviously I should have seen
that he was an oppressive narcissistic
abuser because he didn't want me going
to the beach in a thong and they will
literally think that that is a sign of
narcissism and abuse and it's like why
why do you want to get married and be in
a relationship if you want other men to
see her ass like that doesn't make any
sense but it's like what we have
normalized and it's the expectation
we've trained women to have now so it's
like yeah you yeah you can have any
everything is there anything okay a
bargain what's the bargain okay so I
think feminism was a Faustian bargain I
think it was basically a deal with the
devil where it's like
you're offered this feminism sells this
lie to women that they're going to be
empowered they're going to be sexually
liberated they can have it all you can
have a family and a career and a husband
and you can have a high body count and
you know you can have everything you can
have all these things
um and it doesn't ever work out in real
life and like I said for the vast
majority of women they don't get that
high-powered career they're working a
crap job that they don't love
um because they have to pay their bills
or maybe they like their job but it's
not like the Dr every everyone thinks
they're going to be a fashion designer
or a CEO or a boss and that's not the
reality for most women and
um even for men a lot of men who
supported feminism thought they were
getting free sex out of the deal no
strings attached and it turns out then
they end up in family court right and
it's like yeah so we all got sold this
dream this dream of gender equality and
feminism and Liberation and it's
destroyed life for everyone and the
reason I do this the reason I'm out here
writing these books talking to you is
because I care above and beyond anything
else about kids and the lives of
children and how children are raised and
what their life is like growing up and
those children become the dysfunctional
adults that we're dealing with now so I
feel like Society has a vested interest
in in fixing these problems but yeah
it's We've Ended up destroying ourselves
with feminism feminism has destroyed
society and therefore it affects men it
affects women it affects children it
affects the fabric of reality because
now we're dealing with Erasure of women
because of the movement stuff so it's
like it was a very Faustian deal women
thought they were getting this great
deal out of feminism and it turned out
to be a trap
in my opinion
yeah especially they're like yeah we all
get sex they're like died like 15 of you
do the rest of you will get you get a
born-again virgin let me tell you right
it's like 20 maybe 25 let's be generous
25 the rest
no maybe it was more appealing in 1960
when the BMI was a lot lower have you
ever seen pictures of women at the beach
in the 60s and there's like no fat
ladies and now like what do men get now
now you get a blue-haired feminist with
a liberal arts degree a ton of debt and
a sky-high body count yay okay here you
go what okay what do you see any
solutions going forward like because
to me I'll tell you I'll tell you my
thoughts and I want to hear you because
you you know more than I do like I don't
meet many people that know more than I
do about feminism to be honest most
people think there's three waves still
and I know that but you I'm gonna say
you're more of a feminism expert so my
thought is I think that we should ban
all the child support [__] I think I
want to just banish it I don't I don't
care
um yeah you made your bed lie in it
that's my thought most of you aren't
stay-at-home wives so this doesn't
really make sense anymore get rid of the
child support get rid of the alimony May
who have the lever get rid of no fault
divorce give the lever the if anyone
leaves
um well if no fault divorce you're stuck
you can't do anything anyway haha
um and maybe
I kind of want to ban
take away with I know I know that's
crazy but that's perfect now I don't see
this as practical or probable I don't
think this will ever happen so I'm
curious what would your ideal solution
be and what would your your practical
right right I do have both of those
things so yeah I agree with you it's you
know you can't put the [__] back in the
horse so the likelihood of overturning
meant or control or I mean we did make a
little progress with overturning Roe v
Wade but even that hasn't gotten it
hasn't done what people I think hoped it
would do so
I don't think it's likely that you're
just gonna Outlaw stuff and fix things
that way
um if I could if I had a magic wand
that's what I would do I would
um I would get rid of well I'd get rid
of universe in general but certainly
um this country America wasn't even
suffrage is one person one vote
everybody over 21 can vote oh yeah yeah
let's I'll yeah let's get rid of it and
there's lots of different way yeah
because it's like look around at all the
people go to Walmart go to Walmart and
ask yourself if you want all of those
people deciding your future yeah but it
wasn't founded like that American
democracy even the Republic wasn't
founded that way there were stipulations
and there's many ways you could go about
it you could say only male heads of
households can vote you could say only
male Property Owners or something like
that there's a bunch of ways you could
do it that would be better than just
everyone gets a vote but certainly women
voting through everything completely out
of whack so I would if I could wave my
magic wand do that and women scream and
yell and they're like you're taking away
our rights it's like first of all I'm
not doing anything I'm just talking
about a purely hypothetical if I could
which I can't but yes I would take that
away I would get rid of no fault divorce
I would get rid of
I I probably would have something where
if you got divorced because there was an
extreme extenuating circumstance that
yeah probably the man would be better in
a lot of ways to have the custody I me
and my sister ended up going to our dad
because our mom was so unstable and off
the wall and things like that and it was
a huge relief for us because even though
my dad wasn't perfect it was just more
stable life was more stable
um
so I would think something like that
would be better but I think the real
solution of what we could do
I always say the bad news is that women
are easy to propagandize but the good
news is that women are easy to
propagandize so people like you I think
you're super important because you're
reaching a younger demographic than I
ever would with my books and things like
that which is why I really appreciate
you having me on to have a conversation
um but younger women like you who are
kind of looking at the situation like I
did at your age going wait a minute this
seems really messed up this seems really
jacked like what's going on here
um I think most women if they could if
they really thought it was realistic to
have a stable marriage have kids and
stay home they would and the reason I
think that I end the book with this
Simone de Beauvoir was a existential
philosopher from France who was a
feminist philosopher in the 20th century
and she said in a famous interview in
the 70s with Betty Friedan we cannot
allow women to have the choice of
staying home and raising children
because if they do too many of them will
choose it most will choose that so we
have to force feminism on them because
they're not going to go for it
themselves and I think
the reason I write the book you doing
your shows some of us who are breaking
through this feminist Matrix are showing
women like hey you got tricked into this
you're propagandized into it
uh it's not doing for you what you
thought it was it's all a big lie if
most women could stay home and have kids
and have a community life with their
family that's what most women actually
would prefer like my oldest daughter's
22 and she she does have a job right now
because she's not married and she called
me one day and she goes mom I get it now
we go to work all day and we pretend
it's awesome and it sucks she's like
working sucks we're all just sitting
around pretending it's awesome when
really having to get up and just work
all day and she's like I pay rent which
is a waste of money I live with
roommates she's like I would far rather
be married and putting you know all my
effort and everything I'm doing every
day into my own future with my family
like why would I not want to build a
life with my spouse why do I want to
build a life with roommates or at the
place that I work right now like
she's kind of seeing that yeah this does
kind of suck and it we've been sold a
bunch of Lies so I think we can
propagandize women the other direction
and say this is what I say all the time
don't say I'm just a stay-at-home mom
it's awesome that you're a stay-at-home
mom you are making a huge impact on the
Next Generation by choosing to raise
your children yourself and not Outsource
Outsource that job to a minimum wage
immigrant who doesn't care about your
kids right by choosing to stay married
and keep your kids dad in the home and
in their life you are affecting future
Generations like if you want Power if
you want influence if you want meaning
in your life and you want your life to
matter
choose motherhood choose being a good
wife choose to contribute in all of
these ways to your family to the
community around you we could have a
society again that is built on families
and and long-term thinking about the
future rather than just this consumerist
like uh use it all up before it's gone
get your booty picks out there get the
likes and the clicks and the money and
then I'll worry about getting old when
I'm old and and not thinking about the
second half of our lives so
I think women are not very happy
I think they're looking for Solutions
and if they hear people like you and
people like me explain what has happened
and how we got here and how we can
unscrew the situation I think many of
them will I think most of them would if
they actually had the choice presented
to them that way and if they didn't feel
this intense pressure that they have to
be a career woman or they're going to be
considered a loser do you know any women
by chance I want to do a finance episode
where we go through like what the guy
has to make in order to have like x
amount of kids cost this much because I
think that I've heard that it doesn't
cost as much to raise kids as they
propagate yeah and I really wanted to go
through like okay so women's sake I have
to date a guy that makes this much right
so but it's like I like I've heard that
you can actually live okay off of 40 000
a year on one income yep you just like
move out of the city and you don't take
vacation like yeah and so that's what
I'm been that's like an episode I want
to do soon if you know anyone or if you
want to do it I would love to do it and
I have a whole like folder of stats on
that yes because those statistics I
looked up some of it comes from like the
CDC or the Department of Labor but a lot
of it comes from think tanks where they
are trying to convince people that it's
unrealistic to have kids certainly to
have more than one or two and that both
people should be working and must be
working and things like that
um so it's very biased and if you
actually take into account I have all
these numbers in my little folder if you
take into the account the cost of
mothers working
it you actually aren't making anything
so like say you make you have to make
more than 50 000 a year to really be
making minimum wage as a woman as a
mother when you consider the cost of a
second vehicle ensuring that second
vehicle gasoline commuting back and
forth to work uh your work wardrobe your
lunches that you buy the cost of daycare
um the cost of having to uh miss work
because of your kids and then your job
suffers or you have to take time off for
maternity all these different things
when we tell now I don't care if you
don't ever want to get married you don't
ever want to have kids you can have a
career and be a career woman that's fine
with me I'm mainly concerned with women
and families and mothers being told that
to work like even the Trump
Administration was constantly we're
coming up with programs to get mothers
back to work and I was like why why are
you doing that that's a terrible idea
because I really just like to I like
there's a lot of economic arguments to
be made against mothers working and that
it will raise wages if we have less
labor participation by mothers it will
raise wages for men and things like that
I guess yeah I want to do like because
imagine
um because me it's crazy I grew up rich
but I have the cheapest lifestyle like I
don't even know it's funny because I
like
I'm just not like my my dad it's funny
he does Finance stuff with me and he's
like you make this money but you don't
spend it he's like you spend last year
my personal expenses was 150 pounds
really yeah outside of like food do you
know what I mean like it's nothing I
know girl I don't yeah yeah this month
it'll be higher I bought a dress I was
like there you go yeah but but so I was
thinking like so if a girl says she's 20
right she says I want four kids where
like I want to break through like one
where are our husbands like where should
she look for a husband right because
half of the kids out there nowadays
didn't grow up with functional families
so they don't even know how to they
don't we don't know how to pick right I
know then number two where are they who
are they what do they want and how like
how much do they need to make right
because we like we do have to go down to
numbers you can't just like date a guy
that's a broke no like let's yeah like a
lot of the guys will say oh they're gold
diggers I'm like well they should gold
dig a little bit like I'm not you should
if you want to have a bunch of kids you
gotta have a way to feed them and you
don't want you don't want it to be like
miserable and you're raising your kids
in poverty and depending on the
government so no yeah yeah so I want to
do so like if a girl wants five kids
like you you know and her husband has to
live in a major like well one does her
husband have to live in a major city can
she live outside of the city and he just
commutes like how right what are what
are the options so that's not today
because you know right right no but I
could I could give you a time I would
love to do that yeah yeah I would love
to do that show if you want to do it
like absolutely next week or the week
after sure yeah yeah that would be fun
and that's something people ask me all
the time so I'd love to do a show about
that and get that information out there
and as somebody who has done it myself
like we had to figure that out because
we started when we were young together
with no money
um and I already had a couple kids and
we knew we wanted more it was like it
was tough to figure out we did figure it
out though and I've thought a lot about
it since because people are always
asking me that question so yeah yeah
some good stats and figures on it so we
could do that that would be fun yeah I'm
really bad with numbers so I was like I
am not the person
seem like seem like you know
I'm good with like like stats but when
it comes to like budgeting accounting it
just does my brain
my dad helps me I can't do it um but
okay thank you so much this is what I'm
probably this is probably my favorite
interview I've done this has been so fun
even further today which I thought I was
red pill but every day I get more red
pill
well that's what I'm here to stuff
horse-sized red pills down everyone's
throat
um tell I know you said it at the
beginning but remind them where can they
buy your book website
yes you can find my book on Amazon it's
occult feminism the secret history of
women's Liberation I have a YouTube
channel it's just Rachel Wilson the tag
for it is like at rachel.wilson on
YouTube and I'm on Twitter at Rach for
patriarchy so that's Rach the number
four patriarchy and then sub stack
Rachel Wilson or r wilson.substack.com
well thank you so much Rachel um thanks
for having me on I would love to see you
on like a Joe Rogan or a Tim cat like
you would do so well on one of those
that would be really fun Lord willing
we'll see what happens okay guys uh make
sure you like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and let me know
in the comments who should I bring on
next you know let me let a girl know
like the video on your way out subscribe
go buy your book and I'll talk to you
guys next time